Sam,
Ladies and gentlemen,
we are live.
Goddammit.
We are live with the man.
Jason May Have Miller.
I'm strikeforce fame,
bully beatdown fame.
Fame.
For sure man.
I can't go anywhere.
Let's try force fame to man.
You fought for the fucking title.
Yeah,
that's true.
But.
But you know like strike forces in the
process of building.
Like I could feel them like get the ball
rolling before we even talk.
We have to thank our sponsor.
We're sponsored by the fleshlight.
I left.
That's the butthole version.
I think that's what other version is.
There's a,
there's a mouth version and jj version
now do the bounce coming.
Different races.
That's an excellent point because I was
saying,
how come there's no black ones because
all the vagina is or pink.
If you go to the website,
we're going to talk to them about that.
And the funny thing is the dude who
hooked us up,
the dude who started this whole deal,
our friend Chris,
seems like he's a mixed heritage,
right?
It doesn't mean he seems like he's like,
he's got a bunch of things going to say,
a little bit of black and white ones had
some black something somewhere along the
line.
Let's represent.
He's a spiritual traveler.
You can tell by just talking to that
guy.
I can't believe you guys doesn't have
like Indian dance.
We're going to have him on the podcast
if he'll do it.
He's.
I liked that makes the molds of girls'
vaginas,
like porno stars.
They'd like,
they literally mold their vagina,
like the outside of it.
Stick a flashlight it better and take
them off.
But there was no.
They like put like,
yes,
they put something on it,
you know,
and they make an impression of it.
But every one of those is an official
vagina.
There's like,
or maybe there's just some fat chick
who's her vagina and she's like some
designer.
She went to art school for three years
and then she goes,
puts this stuff on there.
Like now everybody will get.
My point about the flush side has always
been,
it does not have to look like a vagina
because I'm not looking at it.
I'm just shoving it on my desk.
I got a free fake vagina.
One time.
You stare at it while you're fucking.
I'm like,
wow,
that looks like a wheel vagina.
There's no way you're going to be turned
on.
If it was a real vagina.
Okay.
Why is it by itself?
No fucking body.
I know what I mean.
That's creepy.
If you just fuck it.
A vagina like some.
Someone took an apple core to some
chicken,
just pulled it off and out.
In personality wise,
most chicks that I've ever dated are
pretty much just a vagina.
I just see that part already.
Oh,
you've had some cool chicks.
Well,
yeah,
that's true.
But you know,
I've gone through a rash of a
psychopath,
but.
Well there's no.
That's the lifestyle though.
You know,
that's how you're living.
You're a fucking wild man.
Like professional.
There's a lot of people out there
claiming wild man.
Jason May Have Miller's a real fucking
wild man.
All right.
I can't help it.
Shut the fuck up.
You're talking about a dude who,
as long as I've known him,
has been living in hotels,
he doesn't even.
He's now,
he just got a fucking house now.
He has to please God the MTV style.
Well I have to just because like I feel
like when you're like,
I'm damn near 30 years,
like have I been here?
Like buy a house or a TV star now man,
you're legit TV star.
You're,
you're the host of bully fucking beat
down.
That's true.
That's a giant show man.
That is a cultural thing.
Like I'm just waiting to get made fun of
like.
I'm like please,
somebody
thought it lives make fun of this
because it will happen.
It shouldn't.
I mean they can,
they can do that to Anthony Bourdain and
they can do that to you if you go to
any,
any like MTV parties where you have to
hang out with the Yo.
Nah,
they don't let me around those guys and
they separate me from Jersey shore but I
really think.
But you might smack them around.
Might brought my career because I'll be
beaten up about mayhem.
Like I've known him for a long time now
and May.
I was one of the coolest guys I've ever
met.
He's a down dude.
He's totally straight,
you never know you.
There's no way.
There's no guessing where you coming
from,
what may him.
But that said homeys got a switch and
every now and then he just decides.
He just decides to.
We were at the sky bar.
This is classic mayhem and granted,
this is years ago,
before he had matured,
you were very bored so easily.
When you get crazy you get hyped,
you know,
and there's nothing wrong with that.
That's what makes you a great fighter.
But when you got weird the sky bar and
we're just having a good fucking time.
All right.
We got a buzz on were laughing and
telling jokes.
It's like mayhem and Brian is there and
Aria was there and it was just me and
you and I may have.
I think there was one other guy.
No,
because I already hit around the corner
and was like,
oh my God,
I totally had one other dude with no,
no.
Anyway,
bottom line.
Is it okay?
Say it's all just us three.
So we're having a great time laughing
our asses off and mayhem gets hyped and
decides to sky dive on this bed filled
with people,
drinking people.
They have these like the waste Chi
Biros,
skybox wind.
It's got this killer view,
right?
It's at the Mondrian has got this killer
view and they have these beds laying
around and people just chill on these
beds and they lie down and drink.
Well these people just lie in feed up
hard day at work.
You know what I'm saying?
All girl,
girl,
Girl.
Let me tell a story.
Okay.
You got the,
you got the basics.
Rogan told his version.
Here's my version in my head.
Okay.
I'm standing there.
We already been this guy before,
the day before I went with you they for
and I had a blast.
It was like,
girl this time it was like some people
there but it wasn't popping off.
Right.
We're talking about having a good time,
but it wasn't like,
it wasn't like the Hollywood party that
you,
you imagine.
Right.
And I'd never been to Hollywood.
That was like my first time.
Okay.
So I wanted the Hollywood party,
like I was like,
where's all the hot bitches,
you know,
like what,
what is this?
So,
but you know,
you guys are used to it.
So you were like whatever.
Me,
I was getting bored.
Like I was like man,
where the chicks yesterday where I was
talking to chicks and then I look
around,
I'm like,
and then as I look around,
there's a lull in our conversation.
I look over and there's a hot chick and
she's looking at me from the bench now
be it.
I was on the second level of this little
area and we're sitting there talking.
There's a low in our conversation.
I look back at a chick.
She was smiling.
Something in my head said,
Jason,
she wants you to jump on there.
Now.
I have extensive experience jumping on a
couch.
I had a little sister all growing up.
I can run and jump perfect and land
perfect on the couch.
As I ran and jumped in midair,
I went,
Damn,
this is a bad idea.
Like,
why did I do this?
But too late I could not take it back.
So I jumped in,
smash into these all these hot chicks
chicks,
like a bunch of rich dudes wear rolex.
The one guy with my bike,
he hair,
he had the full hawk before people had
full hawks and I smashed it,
knocked the drinks everywhere and
whatever at meant.
I popped up like Bruce Lee,
like jumped back up and I was like,
that was stupid.
I saw bouncing bouncers running and I
just went,
I know,
I know.
I'm sorry.
And then so this is my first Hollywood
thing and I was hanging out with the
famous Joe Rogan and I was like,
damn,
Joe Rogan is going to hate me,
man.
Joe was going to hate me.
I hit my phone rang and I saw Joe Rogan
and I was like,
Oh God.
I answered the phone and he's like,
you were laughing so hard that I was
like,
oh cool.
It's cool.
That was awesome.
You kind of know the difference between
someone,
someone who's capable of doing crazy
shit,
but he's a cool dude and someone who's
just fucking crazy and annoying and
there's a huge difference and you're
just a dude who a cool dude who will do
some crazy shit,
but you get labeled in with the other
group all the time.
You get underestimated in my opinion.
You know,
and it was really funny.
The,
as a fighter as well as the EA game,
they put you at a really low skill level
and it was fucking hilarious.
Video is hilarious.
Video of him on the Internet.
Punking the EA guys.
He pretends that he's fucking pissed
off.
[inaudible] they put them in a low level
of skill way.
Looks so good.
It's so good.
What?
Find it.
Find it on Youtube.
Google.
What is.
Do you know the name of the video?
I don't know.
Oh,
it just may.
May Freak out.
Something like that.
It's on the
abuse or something.
Super quick.
Ryan.
You got it man.
I get to sit back a little bit.
So here I am.
Whatever.
So it just talk us through this for a
lot of people.
Just listen to this setup.
Whole deal.
We went to ea,
so obviously in the middle that actually
one of the this developer.
So if you notice in this video he gets
fucking slapped around.
Here.
It goes here.
Now he starts realizing,
let me show you a few more characters,
a low skill level.
Now you can watch the bro.
What's wrong with bank man?
For you?
What's the buildup?
A big deal to video games.
No,
no,
no man.
No Man.
That's what you pick your.
Yeah.
And then my coach.
No disrespect,
no disrespect.
Yeah.
There was this one dude who was.
There was this one dude who was talking
who was really.
It sounded really freaked out when you.
When you got violent and physical.
He wasn't in a.
no,
no.
My bad.
No,
no.
He wasn't in on it.
That,
that was really his freak out.
The whole floor of people came to the
door and everyone was like,
acting like they're going to do
something.
I like,
Whoa,
listen to that guy's voice.
Could you rewind it to that one spot
where that one guy wigs this guy.
This is some primal shit,
dude.
You got to listen to his voice that the
terrorists
boy's what's wrong?
Charges the bank man was a big deal to
video games.
No,
no,
no man.
No Man.
That's what you paid back your.
Yeah.
That guy.
That guy sounds like a dude is getting
attacked by a bear.
Scared.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I mean,
and I never think about it,
you know,
and I have no fear of physical
altercation talking to them.
Sorry.
It was that bad,
but I didn't have no fear of physical
altercation.
So to me,
like I'm like,
okay,
whatever.
It's a dude,
you know,
like,
and I don't really think about the
consequences.
Anyway.
I got my.
Well if I get beat up I get beat up,
you know,
like,
well the designer wasn't going to fire
you up.
No,
I wouldn't even attempt that because
you're mad at him for that.
You think my game sucks.
Fuck you.
What'd you think he was going to attack
you?
No,
no,
no dogs in that race.
You had no worries.
That was very funny though.
It was very funny though.
Real shit with video Joe Rogan.
I enjoy the shit out of it.
May Have Miller.
I enjoy the shit out of it now.
We can't have you on without talking
about that strikeforce Bra.
Yeah.
That is the most ridiculous shit I've
ever seen on television.
This is one of the problems and we
talked about it on the show right after
it happened with uh,
organizations that they don't have
enough experience yet.
There's little things they haven't
covered.
Little things like watching the doors,
like you can't just let anybody in and
the UFC knows that.
So they have people watching the doors
trying to get into the cage feed man
just,
but there's just like a little hole
missing in their game.
And the whole missing
was you got to watch the door.
You can't just let anybody in the cage.
They just fucked up.
And I thought it was an appropriate time
to get into case smart.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
What's the worst that could happen?
Well,
the worst thing happens so.
it wouldn't have been bad.
It wouldn't have been bad.
Well,
what happened was you came in and
interrupted in the middle of his speech.
Here's the,
here's how that went.
He looked at you,
I saw what happened.
He looked at you guys made eye contact
and then you just went with it because
it was like awkward at that point
because I,
I,
I didn't mean to step into his frame.
And then he looked back at me and me and
me and uh,
me and shields Kinda had made peace
already because we're both cutting
weight at the same time and we're in the
same area.
And we both were like,
oh.
And we're like,
we kind of looked at each other like,
yeah,
we're doing it again.
Like,
what's up Dawg?
Like that.
Like we were like,
alright,
it's cool.
Yeah,
you beat me in the last five.
Give me another shot.
I'll,
you know,
I'll kick your ass.
And I thought,
you know,
there's mutual respect him.
He respects me and an ad.
So we kind of made our peace and that
the way we still,
we're cool.
We're like,
what up?
Then I won my fight and knock the guy
out,
which this will make a lot more sense if
on the video.
I mean,
all the CBS broadcast,
they showed my fight,
but they had five,
25 minute fights and went over their
time slot anyway when way,
way,
way over their time slot.
They went over by like over an hour.
Right.
Wow.
In our planning again,
they're just,
you know,
they're just new at the MMA game.
It's a new thing for them.
Anyway.
Uh,
so I go in there and I didn't mean to
step into frame.
I stepped in the frame of,
Oh whoops,
I've already had.
He noticed me at that moment.
I was like,
well,
I got to talk now Eddie,
because he asked me,
well you want to rematch it out?
And he said that off the off the mic.
And I went,
yeah,
where'd my rematch buddy?
Woops.
Because then I just proceeded to get to
stockton dog piled.
And the funniest part is,
is imagine if I just want to fight and
my camp was in there.
Okay.
My crew,
if we jumped on somebody,
they would be fucking hurt.
I got up like,
oh my God.
Like I didn't even get hurt on that.
How did I even get hurt?
You know,
like I was shocked.
I didn't even have a scratch on me and,
and I,
during the little scrub I shot a double
leg on somebody because I was like,
man,
let me just take someone on the ground
and then I can probably get my way out
of this.
And,
and because I was thinking at this
moment you got when you fight,
and my adrenaline had already been
pumped up earlier that night.
I wasn't even hyped with that.
It was happening.
I was like,
Whoa,
oh my God.
And I'd get on the bottom of a dog pile
and I'm like,
oh,
I'm getting jumped on national
television.
I got kicked in the head and I didn't
even feel that.
And as soon as I'm thinking in my head,
man,
I'm getting jumped on national
television to fricking idiot.
Gus Johnson goes,
gentleman,
this was national television.
I'm like,
dude,
that dude is.
He to me is like commentator in the
fucking you title to your opinion,
sir.
Joe Rogan,
who's got nothing bike.
She'll bellow.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Gus Johnson all day.
He sounds like a dude who's in a mold,
just fits and starts talking like a
sports guy.
I'm just got me pregnant.
I.
I wrote a preface for a book this kind
of like a college textbook.
It's a great book.
It's A.
I can't remember.
Anyway,
it's about the mentality of fighters and
he did case studies with all interviews
with Gus Johnson.
Did this.
No,
no,
no.
How?
How's that guy going to write?
A friend of mine,
he wrote this book and a book called.
I don't know.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
It's coming to me.
It's too complicated.
That's the problem.
If it was just like fighting or fighting
an art,
you know,
it was about that.
It's actually,
you know,
a,
a good book.
I don't know.
Look it up.
Red Band,
you know how to and fucking fighting and
breakfast.
I'm sure it's on Amazon or something
like that.
May Have prefaces.
You never know.
Man.
I wrote this thing where at the
beginning,
and I drew the parallel.
Oh,
but Mascara probably come here.
We have a technical difficulties with
the wiener dog.
Dog,
dog.
My cats in the room.
My cat's hiding in the closet.
The wiener dog found them.
We got goddamn problems.
What kind of fucking professional
studios.
But I had a buddy.
You can't go down there.
Come on here.
Hey,
I'm going to call gentlemen.
We apologize,
but I,
you know,
it's got to be a pretty big coincidence
if,
if he just,
he just.
Sorry guys.
Yo,
check it out.
Podcast son.
But uh,
we have the widest spot anyway for the
people who haven't seen this.
This is what happened.
There was a fight is over google.
Google number one.
Listen to this.
Listen to this podcast at,
don't know shit about mma.
There's most of the people that listen
to this podcast,
I would say probably 50 percent at least
I know.
I love it.
Comedy fans,
people driving a work.
This I just,
just for the people who who are not mma
fans,
we just have to clean it again.
Get it,
get over here.
This is very distracting.
Anyway,
sorry.
Why don't you guys talk for a second.
Let me shut this door.
Please shut the door.
By the way,
remember that couch story?
You're talking about the Sky Bar?
Yeah.
That was like my first month in La and
it was like my first
time at an La bar and then at meets you.
And then when that happened,
I just remember it turned into bullet
time where I just see girls like fucking
glasses of wine every call that saving
private Ryan,
you're like looking around everything
because it black and white and slow
motion.
And then I ran around the corner.
Me and Joe hid from you.
Oh Man.
I knew.
I knew it was going down there.
I'm like,
Damn,
I'm an idiot man.
Like I do stupid shit all the time,
but this is really stupid.
And I was like,
man,
I finally have a famous friend in my
entire life and I tell them to fuck off
exception.
Oh,
not yet.
Everybody says all the time,
we got to keep talking.
Hold on a second before we changed the
dinner.
You're ready.
I'm gonna.
Go see it tonight,
Bill.
For sure.
Do it.
We're not done.
Why?
Partially because at red band tweeted,
like Maddie was stroking himself.
Why he was writing this review like 140
characters of.
Oh Shit.
Oh God.
Like before,
before we get full years old,
we've got to go back
this whole strikeforce thing for your
dog.
Cat.
Sorry.
We got issues.
You got wild kingdom going on up in this
pitch.
Um,
so the,
the,
the strikeforce thing.
So for the people who haven't seen it,
this is what happens.
One guy wins.
And this guy who want jake shields
mayhem and jake shields had fought in
the past very close decision as matter
of fact,
at the end of the second round was the
second or the third or the end of the
second and third,
he had them locked up in a rear naked
choke and homeboy was going asleep.
Hold him.
After the bell was my last fight.
I illegally kicked Jacques Rey in his
head and I was like,
Ooh,
I don't want to get the.
Everybody hates me because I'm a dirty
ass fighter,
you know,
so I didn't even hold onto it and beyond
the bell because I was like,
I'll get up.
He would have went to
sleep and he was,
he was a couple of seconds away from
going to sleep.
It was woulda,
Coulda,
shoulda deadlocked on.
Anyway,
so the point is,
there was a,
they had a big,
very close fight.
It was very,
it was exciting and a mayhem doesn't
feel like he did his best,
which no fighter ever does.
So he wanted to have this rematch.
So when Jake shields one and a big
victory over Dan Henderson may him says,
well,
this is a good way to hype the fight up.
This would be a big name fight.
You know,
I may have Miller from MTV and bully
beat down and we're on fucking CBS right
now.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a famous MMA guy.
You're a famous MMA guy.
You just had a huge victory.
Let's make some money.
Let's make some fucking money.
That's exactly,
let's get fucking.
Come on,
let's get crazy.
let's hype this up.
You've got to get mad at me.
But the problem is everybody took it
street.
Everybody went goofy like,
come on man.
You guys have to have some sort of an
understanding that there's a certain
amount of shit you should be able to
talk before you throw it down because
it's good for business.
It's good for business.
What's not good for businesses,
punting people in the headway down.
Just I understand where you're coming
from.
You want to back up your boy,
but you can't do that on TV.
You got to realize that a lot of this
disrespect and the shit talking,
it's not real.
A little bit,
a little bit like I said,
being hammer and deb locker room,
we suffer together.
This reality
like the reality is,
you know,
it was a great fight.
The reality is,
you know,
you would like to get back in there and
the reality is,
you know,
you think you can beat them.
You can't close to tapping.
So,
so there's a lot of real hype to it,
but there's always respect,
like the,
the,
all the bullshit and the shit talking
and everything like that.
What people have to understand is that
makes you money.
That sells the fucking fights.
That's a big,
big thing.
Like Rashad and rampage man.
If neither one of those guys said a word
to each other,
that wouldn't have been happy.
Emotional black guy fight.
Who Cares?
But I'm just saying they hyped it up.
Yes,
they made realistic.
There's some reality to it,
but they kept the shit together.
They got so close on that ultimate
fighter show,
man,
when they got in each other's face and
touching noses.
Australia,
I'm friends with both guys.
I'm friends with both of those as a
minor because they're cool guys.
They're both great guys.
I grew up with rampage.
Basically when I moved to California and
my damn van,
I like bay.
I,
I lived in the parking lot down the
street from his house and would drive to
go pick them up,
take them to another gym to train.
Everyday we hung out everyday it.
Which one conversation that he
remembers?
I went,
man,
you should be Mr.
t on it on the 18th.
And then he started spitting.
That appeared.
It was done.
I like that.
And I was like,
whoa.
My,
your see I told you didn't magic mayhem
five,
eight years later.
Got Traction type shit son.
Yeah,
exactly.
Anyway,
maybe I'm just magic Joe Rogan.
Maybe he's just really saw God just
blessed me.
I got to know me and shit.
Hey.
Anyway,
up.
So we're in Australia and those guys
were both out there and I'm kind of
kicking it with both of them going
around to Australia's nightlife and uh,
I'm,
I'm kind of hanging out more with
rampage.
I'd known him for a way longer and
whatever.
And I kinda,
you know,
I haven't seen him.
We were catching up and,
and anyway,
he a Villi.
These guys,
suddenly I'm in the nightclub with some
hot chicks.
I'm looking around like,
wow,
hot chicks,
cool.
This is what life's supposed to be.
Right?
And security starts running past me and
I'm like,
where's rampage?
And I like looked over at and where were
shod with city,
where's Rashad?
And I was like,
dude,
they're not here.
And those guys were running.
I run down to this little tiny hallway
where the bathroom was and who's
standing there face to face in this
hallway that I could barely fit down.
They are face to face in this thing.
Just black guy talking like little
motherfucker.
A motherfucker like I all I could hear
as much as people bitch.
And here we go.
I was like,
aw dude,
these,
these security is like locked.
They know who these guys are.
They know what can go down right now.
They're just like,
ah,
fuck.
Could you imagine to the restroom at a
fucking club in Australia?
Sydney people are cool as fuck.
Yeah,
like people are nice here.
How hard it to be a bouncer,
you know,
no big deal.
And then one day to fucking cage
fighters,
fabens fighting one of the biggest rival
reason the history of the UFC.
And these two guys are in each other's
face in your bar and you've got to do
something to the rescue.
I sprint the doubt in their gap between
him and explained to them in the
language that I'm accustomed to black
guy because I can talk black guy,
black guy.
Oh,
give us,
give us an exact interpretation of what
a normal black guys,
this black guy.
Like I,
I,
my formative years were spent with all
black guys.
My front 12.
Well I moved to a less black
neighborhood when I was 12 and whatever
it was still does.
I still hung out with black kids because
I was already used to that.
Like I was just like,
you know,
that was just my normal guy.
What's it feel like?
So,
you know what I mean.
Hey,
get outta here.
So anyway,
I get it.
These guys faces and like,
Hey man,
let's do this on TV.
Huh?
Why are you guys gonna waste the right
here because international incident they
kinda like broke off and Kinda like
laughed the fact that screaming about an
international incident and disaster
averted.
But like they were furious.
Yeah.
They were like,
I was like,
you guys are really a couple of drinks.
These guys get fired up.
Well,
there's a psychological advantage of not
getting the other guy,
you know,
not backing down at all.
It's so important to those guys and they
understand that.
I mean,
it seems stupid and I think it is kind
of dumb,
you know,
but I understand it 100 percent and you
know,
look,
when people get heated in to each
other's faces and you know,
and there's this,
especially with two guys that are about
to fight these little tiny battles are
real.
These little tiny psychological battles
like who gets to tell who to go fuck
themselves last,
you know,
who gets to say the last word?
You know,
it's like,
fuck man,
we might be here all day.
I'm not going anywhere fucking on
getting that real man.
I am so not.
Why would you want to get yourself that?
That's true.
It's true.
But if you're a cage fighter,
it's a different situation because
psychological warfare,
it's very important.
It's very important.
Your mindset as opposed to where their
mindset is.
When,
when the fight starts,
you can fuck someone's head up in the
preflight,
but there's a lot of fighters that are
awesome,
believe in,
just like I love you.
That's all nice and good,
but everybody's got their own style,
right?
You can't hate on someone's shit-talking
stop because it really works,
man.
There's some,
there's some shit,
man,
when you get inside someone's head and
get them emotional.
And I'll start talking shit about their
girlfriend talking shit about their kids
talking shit about their life.
You,
you start fuck.
And look,
some people can take it.
Some people who talk shit,
um,
and they think it's funny and it doesn't
hurt them,
but some guys go crazy.
Look at fucking Frank Mir.
When Brock Lesnar Frank Mir his face
after he beat the fuck out of him,
after he beat his fucking face into the
ground to smashed him,
then he gets in his face doc.
So fucking shit.
Use
that for motivation.
That,
that was real man.
That was,
that was,
uh,
a real anger.
You know,
that guy got fucking furious because
that,
it backfired on him.
But it works on other girls.
What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
Backfired.
Well,
I think that people got sad that.
No,
no,
no.
I mean as far as his performance,
his performance,
all the shit talking to backfire.
I just think that that had nothing to do
with property is going to be bigger and
stronger and bigger groups.
But what I'm saying is it didn't do any
good.
He got it more of a beating,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
and he got really.
He got real anger behind shit out of me.
Then they let me off easy,
you know,
I,
I to,
if I lost,
I had lost.
I want to lose.
I don't want to like,
Oh,
you hugged me into the Damn Bat.
I wonder like,
did you see the IFC,
the,
uh,
Josh Barnett Dranamo dose?
I didn't see you like stoppage,
man.
I mean,
Josh Barnett was crushing them.
No,
don't get me wrong.
You mean it's definitely just.
But I was thinking like,
wow,
I don't know.
I think Brock Lester took more shots
than than this guy and the guy got up
and he was really pissed and he
protested was like,
what the fuck?
And granted Barnett was killing them.
Don't get me wrong.
Barnett looked awesome.
I mean he been at fucking Barnett as I
loved the officiating and the Lesnar
fight listener.
I'm a supercar one fan.
Like I love him as well.
He's the best guy.
Look,
I'm a fan of anybody who can.
When Brock lesner showed his character
and coming back for that second round,
but he took a lot of shots where I was
looking at big John,
who I think is the best of business.
I think big John and herb dean at the
very best and big but big.
John stopped that fight in Australia.
It was like,
I wonder who would have stopped the
lesnar fight?
People would have stopped it.
Yeah.
I know.
Most of all is the shit.
That guy is one of the best.
Rosenthal.
Rosenthal is the shed.
He's a real fan.
He trains.
He's a brown belt in Jujitsu.
What about understanding what her dean
is the shit.
He's my dean is stellar,
outstanding,
coolest motherfucker on the planet.
You both guys are and you know,
but I don't think either one of those
guys could have stopped it.
Maybe.
Maybe herb herb might have stopped now.
I don't think he would have.
Somebody might have no one from the
matrix is going to stop.
That is a great referee,
but he might've stopped it.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
There's a few.
I mean what I'm trying to get at is that
moments like that you realize how
important the referee really is.
Yeah.
The thing is that,
I don't know.
I don't think he should have been
stopped because he was taking a beating
for sure,
but if you look at the athletes face,
you have to like pay attention to their
facial expression and there if they
don't look like they want out of there,
why stop it?
Like I never once can remember.
I remember getting my ass kicked a
couple of times.
Like I like getting kicked and I
remember thinking,
don't stop this fight.
Like don't stop it.
I'm still here.
Don't worry.
I'm still here and keeping my faith.
But that's an extra thing to think
about,
right?
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
but I just know in my head,
don't stop the fight because I could
tell it a couple of bites I been and
where I'm getting my ass whooped,
I could tell.
I'm like,
Whoa,
I'm getting kicked my ass kicked right
now.
I got to hurry up and get out of this
situation and I.
But at the same time,
begin.
Don't stop.
Please don't stop the fight because I'm
still here.
Have you talked to the Diaz brothers or
Melendez and anybody
that was involved in his truck for
Thrall Melendez?
Yeah,
he's cool.
Like it would be an email that does been
cooled at buddies on and I was actually
kind of friends with Nate Diaz despite
being nick never getting along because
you think you guys can all squash.
Oh,
you don't get along with nick.
Fuck Nick Diaz.
Whoa.
Long words.
I said it anyway.
What is your problem?
No,
because you know what?
I feel like he was a driving factor in
that whole thing.
He's the first guy to throw a punch.
He started that whole thing and it,
it's almost not as fault because he's
retarded,
but at the same time and he embodies
this cultural shift that we had and,
and we really,
really started with Dr Dre selling us
Nwa and it did add saunas.
This culture of gangster is cool.
Gangster is cool in a way to watch a
movie,
but being gangster is just being a
little kid,
you know what I mean?
And,
and starting a big brawl because what?
I talked some shit to your homie that is
just ghetto and that,
that,
that thing embodies what's wrong with
the paragard right now.
People don't take it.
Like when they asked him about it,
I came out and apologized.
Uh,
right after that whole thing went down
because I was wrong.
I stepped into the cage,
but no one stopped me.
I figured that they won't mind.
It'll be cool.
That'd be a cool way to.
Amanda.
Come on,
man.
You figured myself.
Sorry.
Anyway,
so you know,
I,
I got,
I got in there,
he jumped on me that that's not the
proper response.
Like,
you know,
you don't act like a damn Brian.
Come on
in the middle of the speech pattern.
Yeah.
So I mean,
you,
you had talked to nick in the past
though,
you guys pop was,
is that right?
Nick will after one fight I did pretty
good because after one of these,
one of his fights I was doing the post
fight interview Miller with.
That's usually I did.
I didn't know setup.
It was like a silly and it's just a
joke,
like he didn't get the joke though.
That's the problem he was just fucking
with.
He's like a serious dude,
you know?
He's like,
dude,
you know what I mean?
Like,
look,
I liked Nick Diaz a lot.
I'm a big fan of him as a fighter.
I've always been cool with him person.
I thought he was great.
Hey listen,
what do you mean?
What is it about him?
That whole no,
no fun,
no fun and games.
That's,
that's a weird way to live because he
just is.
He's,
he's,
I don't know,
he's just angry with himself,
so he just,
he takes.
It's rare that someone is so
disciplined,
like as disciplined his hands.
I mean Nick Diaz is in tremendous shape
just running and cardio guy works really
hard obviously.
He's so good now to man his last few
fights,
man,
the fucking Scott Smith's fight.
I was really impressed.
Frank shamrock.
I was like,
God damn.
He's like,
he's fucking putting it together.
He's putting it on people.
I like that.
But,
but as like a dude like that whole,
like always angry and always fighting.
It's,
you know,
it's unfortunate.
It's unfortunate way of looking at
whatever,
you know.
That's just the mentality of some people
and I think that,
you know,
it's weird.
You see that in someone who's so good at
that.
What do you mean?
You just go to the gym every day at work
to be smart.
There's,
there's a certain amount of,
there's a certain amount of power over
your mind and over your will.
There's a certain amount you have for
her to have a well man,
whatever.
Dude,
listen,
I just have a will and discipline.
You get back.
Those who are dumb as shit,
who would just go to their construction
job and work hard as hell every day.
It doesn't take no.
Listen.
Nick Diaz might not be like you.
You might not think he's socially most
inept guy in the world,
but physically,
that guy's very intelligent.
Look how good as Jujitsu is.
Look how good he fights.
That takes the intelligence.
It's just,
if he's not,
you know,
focusing in other areas of his life,
it doesn't mean that he's not
intelligent.
There's no doubt that guy when you're
that good,
you're super intelligent.
It's just.
I mean,
I,
I understand where it all comes from.
I mean it's,
it's like it's a programming that you
get when you're really young and you
think that that's the way to behave and
act,
but I think you've got a real good
point.
You know,
you've got a real good point about the I
don't want to drive.
I like to have fun and I back wild.
I do crazy stuff,
but you are always cool to be,
but I've never seen you picking fights.
What's the point?
Never seen you start arguments for no
reason.
You've always been cool to people.
I've never seen you bully people or fuck
with anybody,
which is where it really funny that you
wound up getting this anti bully show,
listening.
The same job that I do in vow man.
I did the same thing all growing up.
It's so funny that I got because I
played this role my entire life because
every time there's a big kid picking out
a middle kid,
I can remember like three incidents.
So yeah,
I would be like,
because I like to fight.
I always liked to fight since I was
three years old.
Like I just like my dad was in the army
and box and stuff and he,
he like,
so you weren't afraid of it.
You wanted to get in there and do it and
talking Shit and bullying somebody guy
boot was bullying another little kid.
I remember walking in,
seeing it going down and he was pushing
a little kid around and I was like,
I remember I like,
I don't know,
I guess I was like nine or eight.
I walked over there and got in between
them and then I beat this kid up,
but start
bullying the bullying,
bullying because bullying,
bullying bullies though is a very common
practice.
Lot righteous people do that.
I bullied,
bullied the other today are using blue
torture.com.
My bully in high school,
he used to always fuck with me.
So what?
Fifteen years later I made a website
where I used to take listerine strips
and put them in animals mouse that I
would photoshop like them,
have blue lips and stuff like that and
pay it Peta or whatever.
It got so pissed off that they're like,
we're going to go to this person's house
and protest them.
So I found my bullies address and made
this big flyer like got five new puppy's
going to give them 200 strips,
the on the Internet and here's.
Stop right now.
Stop.
Right now.
Don't be admitting this on the Internet.
What's wrong with you?
Stop what you're talking about.
No,
it's fine.
I've already admitted at anytime on the
artist.
Well,
not on this fucking podcast.
Nobody else listened to rap to didn't
mean to do it.
The Guy,
Huh?
It doesn't matter.
I got the wrong address.
Okay,
well,
the way you never address,
you got cycle to some random person's
house.
Worse.
Dude,
let's stop talking.
Stop talking.
Jesus Christ legality.
No.
Let's.
While we're on that subject,
tell me mayhem,
the story of your,
your assistant that did you wrong and
justice,
which I think is 100 times worse than
what it's not because you do.
You gave a waste where someone lives.
That's where someone loves his thinking,
I guess.
Yeah.
That's where someone sleeps.
This is just a phone number.
A phone number is not nearly as bad as
the place where you sleep.
The rest of the story was.
What was weird about it is that he was
arrested the same week that this
happened for a torture to an animal.
He left his dog in his house for like
weeks at a time while he was out doing
other bad stuff and so it just happened
at the same week,
which made it a million times better
without doing other bad stuff.
Bad stuff.
The way he speaks as well.
I'm trying,
I'm trying not to get the guy in trouble
or appointed Adam.
All right,
well we could move onto subject revenge
was served so you don't have to worry.
Okay,
good.
So now we can all sleep knowing that you
won't be.
No legally,
but it's weird because actually he was
abusing animals.
The whole thing is funny.
If someone trust into a scam and gets
busted,
you know,
an interesting story is the guy who,
uh,
you know,
people always ask,
hey,
can we take a picture?
Will you get me in a choke or I'll get
you in a choke?
And I say we can't because the UFC
specifically tells us we can't because
two guys were sued.
Uh,
chuck was sued and Matt Hughes were sued
for taking pictures with Duke.
But then why did Jim Norton just get
choked out the other day on opb video?
Video is totally different because a
video.
No,
no,
no.
Listen to video is very obvious what's
happening.
You know,
and by the way,
it's Jim Norton.
Jim Norton's not going to sue randy
coture.
It's just random fans.
And thought they could make some money
and they pretended that chuck heard
them.
They pretend that Matt Hughes heard him.
Well,
the guy who they pretended Matt Hughes
heard them.
Apparently they investigated this
because there's always people that said
like,
come on man,
that's bullshit.
Matzoh.
Nice guy.
Who's taking a picture with you?
You asked him to do it.
This guy turned out he was a dirty cop
and they started investigating and found
out some shit.
And now he's in jail doing a long
stretch.
Was doing like 10 years or something.
You know why?
Because he's a Christian.
And Jesus did it.
Jesus.
Fuck that.
Do the ass.
That's what happened right there.
God.
Jesus came.
The worst thing ever sat on a podcast.
Visual it'd be a worse thing to get
raped by alleging getting raped by
Jesus.
Bad Shiva,
the destroyer.
That's a way better.
So,
uh,
tell us what happened with this.
This may have,
is,
uh,
like I said,
one of the nicest guys I know,
totally down boil dude.
But he had an issue with.
I had the worst assistant ever.
Like literally like I'd be like Eddie
take a right on ocean and a right on
California.
All right,
right on.
No Shit right on top.
Just to make a name for this guy.
His name is.
Um,
how about Mike?
Is Mike good mix?
My Dad's name,
title,
Tonya harding?
No,
don't say Tonya harding.
Let's just call them Tanya.
Call Tiny.
Tiny.
I just take a right on ocean.
Take a right on California.
Got It.
And he's like,
oh.
And my friend goes,
it's a big yellow building.
So I walked to the building,
I told,
I told him to go to and I'm waiting for
15 minutes and I'm like,
what the hell?
Finally I called the guy.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
Oh,
oh I,
I,
he's just stupid established.
She's very poor.
It is Joe.
Okay.
So maybe come in with a bit.
Fucked you over.
Let's get on track.
I set it up so you know what I was
dealing with here.
Okay.
So I'm keep giving them another chance
every time.
So he can't pay my credit card.
Bill.
Take two minutes to do it.
He has all the information,
still couldn't do it.
He can't figure out travelocity.
He booked me an hour away from my family
reunion.
Like either he's,
he's terrible at his job.
Okay.
So he then goes to one of my close
friends and just lies about everything.
Like,
like it's a girl.
So one of your close friends,
this guy found her information and
contact high.
He went,
somehow he got her email on the email,
had to be hating.
There's only one reason why guy does
that.
Guy Goes and talks to a girl to talk
shit about,
you know.
Oh,
don't worry.
I'm well aware of that.
So,
uh,
you know,
this guy freaking calls her.
It just starts making up ridiculous
stories.
The girl believes it.
She believes it.
Totally believes that event is like
totally.
I'm like,
what the hell?
Where he says a bunch of bad shit.
A bunch of bad shit about me.
Yeah.
You're very emotional.
A hard time getting this out.
They are.
Yeah,
they are.
Yeah.
It's fucking sucks,
man.
Sensitive.
But yeah,
fuck me over.
Finally I get the story out of her.
She tells me why I'm like,
what?
Like he has made all that shit up,
like really cheap.
We make up.
He told me he showed me all that.
I'm like,
man,
I suffered for like a week or two where
she was just giving me the boot,
like no reason and I don't know why.
And you didn't know what it was and I
didn't know what it was that all
stabbing you in.
The guy that I fired the week before
because he's inept at his job and I was
totally cool with them too.
So you had already fired him and then he
fired him and then he did all that.
Oh,
I was confused.
I,
my body did all this while he was
working.
Oh,
okay.
So then,
so you fire him,
he talks shit about you to this girl
that he was probably in love with you.
And then what do you do?
You put.
Oh No,
I was talking to my friend Dane and
I totally knew I was talking to my
friend Dane Cook while you were talking
on twitter,
but twitter and of that guy's number
that I thought I saw that I saw him.
He did that,
so I,
you know,
I was like,
yeah,
call,
call a guy.
Anyway,
I talked to him.
So you thought you were making a direct
message to Dane Cook and you were really
just twittering in public day.
That happens because I can't figure out
how to delete the nice people on twitter
leaking your phone number.
So intensive because that's like
something that you have so many,
like a hundred people that know your
phone number and once you leak that,
like Dana white just leaked it on
twitter the other day.
You can lose that of did with his office
number,
so they'll change is,
oh,
that's not bad,
but your cell phone,
that's pretty huge.
You saw what was going on my phone.
I couldn't even turn it a number for a
long ass time.
You're going to forget how many people
have that number when somebody down the
line.
You're trying to reach.
It's all good.
I think this is a great retreat setting.
Re just reaching,
going
back and trying to grab a hold of people
from the past.
Don't let that shit.
It's kind of fun letter.
When you lose a number.
I'd like that to go.
I liked it.
Now I can't even turn the phone on.
I turned the phone on.
It just,
it just reboots because it gets so many
texts because I turned it on like every
day I want to turn it on and had like
5,000
tech.
So let's just reboot and I can't use it.
I try to make a call or I get calls in
on it.
I tried to answer the call and while I'm
answering the call,
it's just constant buzz,
buzz,
buzz of texts coming through buzz buzz
or calling you out on the other line and
then it reboots.
Is that red bad is basically turning
into,
onto the city on that.
I'm putting in my flashlight.
That's he likes to do.
But um,
so unfortunately put this guy's phone
number online,
but I don't think anybody's going to
call it.
Oh,
nobody will call us and Albert.
Right?
Why would there.
Yeah.
It's not like it's my phone.
Oh yeah.
And it's not like you're like there's a
love guy and that guy fucked you over.
You know what I'm saying?
Does anybody loves the bullied me down?
Well,
I am.
I am,
uh,
an official mainland monkey.
I'm a member of a number for 20.
That's as Cliche as they make it folks.
I had to take it.
It's perfect,
right?
Yeah,
Bro.
Come on.
Somebody had to before joining mayhem as
a,
a call called the mayhem monkeys.
I'm done with that shit.
So it's easy.
You know what?
I've got to meet him.
Monkey tee shirts.
Two of them at least a general in the
army.
I mean,
at least I can't wait.
Well,
you know what I'm saying?
How about this?
How about I have a cold.
You have a call and we'll be like
fucking favorite nations and shit.
But you think about it.
I just want my cold to be.
People were same.
Have the same mindset.
You are because we're all monkeys
spinning around and rock in space.
Tunnel tubes and tunnel wind tunnel.
That's where we have boys have tubes.
Girls have tunnels for.
I love Brian.
You know why?
Because Brian is a grown man with a
beard,
but he like a 14 year old,
so great.
I like it.
I love that personality,
man.
That's,
that's a unique motherfucker right
there.
Did you ever get your male monkeys?
Like altogether?
Like for kind of like a roller skating
party or anything like that?
Probably.
I've done that.
I've done that with the Rogan board
members.
It's almost always awesome,
but there's almost always one dude
that's creepy in real life.
One dude that just jacks the parties.
Remember when we did a Houston back in
the.
Yeah.
Who was a good example of that where it
was a couple.
Dude,
I don't remember the names,
but me.
I don't know.
Into My.
I did.
I wouldn't even say it right after the
meeting them.
They stopped.
They just drop off the board.
They stopped coming to the board because
you realize this.
There's been members that wives have
found out that they came to the circle.
Jerks and memory.
There's been affairs.
There's been.
Yeah,
there's,
yeah.
I mean our friend outlaw,
that was a legitimate friend of ours
that died.
He had a heart attack.
He was overweight.
Lowboy dude,
it's a business.
A cool motherfucker.
We've,
we knew that guy from like 2001 was with
them when we first met.
I'm in Houston,
right?
And he was always on my message board.
Just a funny dude.
You're so cool dude.
So you can meet cool people off the
Internet,
but the problem is man,
for every cool dude,
you know,
for every 10 cool dudes,
there's one or two just creepy fucks
that they'll show up for your
percentages on the planet.
Come on.
That's pretty fucking good.
I think you know,
you,
you get to know people very well from
reading the shit they ride on the
Internet.
That's why twitter is awesome because
you get to see is this person a negative
person positive,
funny that you could see through their
tweets because they can't help it.
They put themselves out there who I
love.
I love black dudes that give
motivational talk to.
I like that.
You know,
Tyrese,
that actor,
that dude is always like,
women.
Stand up for yourself in all caps.
Make that man respect you,
baby.
Boy,
before someone else will love you.
Girls like,
he'll like say all this like crazy,
super positive love pimp shit.
No,
he's just slinging his.
I'm a good guy game.
You know what I mean?
It's like I,
his fucking Avatar on twitter is a him
making out with some chick.
Dude is built like a fucking creek.
God who's sexy motherfucker.
I mean,
I don't hate them.
I'm not hating but at.
But I find it hilarious.
He's talking all this super power pro
God love game.
Like you could tell when someone's
throwing a game,
you know what I'm saying?
You can tell when someone's real and
that's who they are.
You can't.
Yeah.
But a lot of people are not as bright as
you are.
Joe Rogan.
Isn't it fascinating when you see
someone's throwing a game and other
people aren't seeing it?
It's like scientology,
you know,
like anything like that.
Like I had this neighbor who was a cool
guy.
I still love the guy and uh,
where I used to live and he was talking
to me about buying this piece of
property and then,
uh,
I said,
well,
I can't do it right now,
but I really want to pick this up
because,
uh,
my wife is about to go clear.
Sorry,
go.
What are you talking about?
He goes,
yeah,
well,
we're in scientology and she's going to
clear and across $50,000
I will.
Otherwise I would pick this piece of
property up.
I go,
Whoa,
whoa.
I go,
what is clear?
Like,
what are you talking about?
So I'm just,
you know,
as a comedian,
automatically I want to start laughing
at him and mocking him.
But then my heckler skills are taking
me,
give them some rope.
Let's talk here.
Let's,
let's find out what we got going on
here.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm listening to him.
He's telling me that his wife is going
to become someone who cannot be
influenced by outside forces.
I'm not fucking with you.
What did,
what did they,
they get them to the point where nothing
negative that anybody does them or
assess them.
Can Affect who they are.
It's really fucking some pretty strong
pimp shit.
If you think about it,
you know someone tells you that they're
going to fix you,
so nothing's going to come in.
What's uncomfortable about as you start
thinking you could do that too.
You start thinking,
I could do that to people.
I could get start writing shit like shit
talking about easily,
easily,
man.
It was a crazy feeling though.
Knowing that I'm living next to some
dude is just getting ready.
We can go down that.
You know what I mean?
Taking 50 grand from him.
Man.
50 wave.
A magic wand idea.
I'll do Goddamn Voodoo ceremony on his
wife so that she won't get affected by
bad buju anymore.
South Park episode without the
scientology thing.
One of the best.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
No.
When they went over the whole marriage.
Oh my God.
It was genius.
South parks are greatest photo history.
Here's the way it is though.
Okay.
The way it is is my friend has a grandpa
from Japan lifted Hawaii,
but basically at for the last 30 years,
been in the house cleaning the house.
She's the nicest lady.
She got one of her friends from,
I dunno,
whatever old Japanese ladies do.
She doesn't speak English,
so they go to a Japanese church,
a Christian church,
and they go,
they are telling the story of the virgin
birth and she suddenly has a freakout.
She's 80 years old.
She's kind of like an old lady like,
you believe this.
Then you in the middle of the sermon
like you all believe this.
This is one that really.
Because that's the first time in a
Christian church.
He didn't never.
She never heard about it.
Really.
She didn't know the story.
Oh No,
it's not.
You know,
she freaked out.
She was like the you guys believe it
fucked up the whole sermon and left in
the middle of it.
But if you draw the parallel to the same
thing,
it's kind of hard to.
Yeah.
I mean,
I hate to use the same thing as
Christianity.
It's just,
it's the 2000 years younger.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
Anybody telling you they've got all the
answers.
They don't have this weird hunger
to to figure it all out,
but I know it's good because now we got
the scientology.
Oh,
sorry,
science,
that scientologist scientists,
real scientists,
and I think it's messed up.
Scientologists put it in there to sound.
I know,
right?
That is kind of fun.
Kind of fun because their coat was
signed because people who don't want to
go to church go,
oh wait,
it
sounds better,
but anyway.
Sites in psychology together meshed up.
Exactly.
But,
but you know,
we all,
we all have this need to know
everything.
That's cool.
These smart scientists are figuring it
out.
You know,
they know that the world around because
they shot definitely shot.
Here's the reality.
Here's the reality there.
Figuring out things about matter.
They're figuring out things about the
nature of reality,
but there's way more to.
The real big question isn't like,
how does this work?
What makes this explode?
What makes an atom?
What makes the big bang?
The real question is what the fuck is
all know?
That's the real question.
That's impossible with just science.
It's going to take evolution and
science.
They're the real thing.
That's going on is we have all this
incredible power right now as a human
race,
but we're still in this crazy adolescent
stage of figuring out how to behave and
think and raise children to be normal
humans.
You know,
I mean,
it's a very strange time when you think
about the power that people have to to
change the fucking world that we live
in,
like with explosions and all kinds of
crazy shit that people have invented and
how dumb people are as well at the same
time.
So many yummy.
Well,
yeah,
but I mean that's the way the world is.
You know,
there's smart people out there and at
those smart people,
both idiots like be around,
but it hasn't ever been as big a
disparity between people who are
intelligent,
evolved and the people who aren't all
living in the same time.
There's actually a lot of the
scientists,
scientists are talking about how things
are going to go in which direction are
they going to go and they're talking
about the elite class of people,
the smart people.
Some scientists say that we're going to
evolve,
evolve just like the time machine.
There's going to be some goods and
there's going to be the super smart,
like crazy genetically enhanced robot
people.
I don't know why people wouldn't think
that's possible.
You know,
people want to think somehow or another,
the human beings,
what we are right now is what?
We're going to stay open and we're not.
We're going to become something else.
You know,
we're gonna.
We're gonna.
Move on to something else,
man.
Who knows what the fuck it is,
but it's not going to stop right here.
I just hope that I get robot arms and
the people look at like other animals,
like they all bunch of different kinds
of subspecies were they branched off and
the humans themselves.
We at one point in time have related to
some other kind of primate primate that
the chimps were related to and they all
went in different directions.
Like,
who the fuck are we to assume that we're
going to.
That it's going to stop.
The branch is going to stop here.
No,
we're not.
I don't think anybody is.
I think that though some piano.
What are you talking about,
man?
Most people fake bid.
We're here,
this is how we're staffed,
where they can't even see that.
The Chinese chick I dated,
her parents are like super short and add
ad.
She just sprung up to like five foot
eight,
you know,
out of nowhere.
Well guess what?
She's eating this chemically processed
food.
Then all of a sudden she gets huge and
she had big boobs.
I'm like,
how?
What?
Your Asian,
your mom,
it's super flat.
Your dad is like a scrawny.
Talked to a woman,
you know,
having more babies
now there's more twins,
chemicals they pumped in or though like
some female steroids.
Yeah,
that was on purpose for sure.
Check did embryos and it happens all the
time that people are like,
they can't have a kid,
you know?
They're like,
God,
I just want to have a baby.
If they eject the leads with a bunch of
hormones,
so she's super fertile baby.
He drops his load inside of her and all
of a sudden you pop out a litter of
puppies and they even put embryos.
So that's what I'm saying.
The actual embryo center,
like old women who no longer have any
air
and their bodies and bodies are starting
to get used to having 12 kids at once
since now.
Would a body be able to have 12 kids,
10 years old?
Well,
I'm hoping to see the turtle woman who
like has all their kids on the beach and
then covers them up with fans.
I think it's a disturbing idea for
people to think that there's going to be
two groups of humans,
intelligent ones and more on one's
literally literally be two different
species because people were worried that
they would be in the moron group.
That's what it is.
Everybody's like,
I don't even want to talk about this.
This is not real.
No bullshit.
People are gonna evolve together.
We're gonna.
Help each other.
Stop thinking like that.
You're a pessimist really.
Well,
watch that fucking news.
Really.
You don't pay attention to some of the
crazy shit that you hear people do.
You hear about people fucking their kids
and going into stores with machine guns
and you don't think that there is
somewhere it some how possible that that
might be a separate subspecies of people
eventually completely unrelated to like
a bill gates like so totally different.
It's just a matter of time,
man.
I,
you know what I'm cool with being on the
lower end.
I'm like,
whatever.
I'll be like the smartest dumb guy.
It'll be all acts.
Weakened.
Savage.
I'd be like,
what?
Seven slash 11.
The food.
You might have a more fun and you might
be getting more chicks.
Smart chicks.
It's hard to get them to commit to a
relationship.
They're very wary of you.
They want to like,
I don't.
You seem like a guy who's gonna like
abused my emotions,
but the DM checks like,
yeah,
hot chased.
The dumb ones are sometimes it's more
fun if you want a party partying with
dumb people,
sometimes there's a lot more fun
partying with smart people.
Want to fucking cry.
Talk to you about their ex husbands and
share with us.
Smoke a joint and then fuck it.
Yeah.
Do you.
I mean,
think about it,
if you're just a guy trying to have a
good time,
you have two options.
One is a girl who's 23,
just got out of college.
She's out with all of her best friends
and they're all drinking.
Okay.
There's that.
Or She's 31.
She's smoking cigarettes.
She just broke up with her boyfriend.
She thinks she might be pregnant.
Who the fuck are you going to talk to?
Who are you going to talk to?
You want to talk to the smart check who
just graduated from college and she's
not exactly sure what she's going to do
with her life and like,
hey,
I just want to dance.
Can we just have a drink and have some
fun?
No,
no.
So if you want to have some fun,
just fun.
Studies.
Studies disagree with rat at age 27 to
45.
It's like a woman's social priority for
sure.
Sexual Prime telling me a 23 year old is
not blowing you.
Bullet
were we're talking about dumb and smart.
Oh,
that's what I'm talking about.
I'm not talking about necessarily the
the,
the age.
I think the chicks are hottest when they
were in their thirties because they
became women and to know each other.
I'm just saying in our theoretical world
of two different subspecies,
you might be better off being king of
the retards because you get a lot of hot
chicks that are just like really easy
and fun to hang out with,
whereas opposed to hanging out with a
lot of smart checks,
like they're going to want a lot of
commitment.
We're going to have to have a
relationship with the president.
We have a black president.
It is the future now and I am the kick
of the retards.
I'm chubby enough in Texas that I'm a
supermodel.
Yeah,
in Texas.
You fit right the fuck it.
Fuck it dude.
Man.
With a guy.
Girls like a man with a little gut in
Texas.
That's Amanda's living bigger's better.
It looked in the old days,
man.
Fat broads were attractive.
That's why those old paintings like fat
met yet somebody.
Yeah,
she so luxurious.
Look,
she gets to get fat because nobody else
got fat man.
You know,
when you look at those old pictures of
fat bitches and you're like,
why is that sexy?
What the fuck was wrong with them?
What was wrong was it was hard to get
food that was there.
Blaine bling,
bling and look,
oh,
that's teddy.
Look at all this shit right here.
I got all fat hanging off my arms and
shit.
That's how much food I guy match.
I don't think they talk like that.
Those pictures were the.
That was the equivalent of dub magazine.
That was the equivalent of MTV cribs.
They were showing their bling.
This is my blank.
Look on my fat.
I just be eating shit.
Pigs and shit all day.
Yeah,
you could be fat and fucked up and you
look like royalty.
Whereas everyone else was sinewy and
they fucking worked all day.
They were built like mayhem.
All these facing.
If I go back at time,
I'll want to plow.
So hood rats that were saying,
well,
when you go back in time,
you know,
maybe you fat chicks,
you'd fall into a world maybe.
Maybe the only reason that guys could
get fat chicks.
It's because they had the gay powdered
wigs zine and it only fat chicks was the
same era.
I don't know if.
I'm not sure.
Whigs went a long way off with.
I think it was get out of that when
Jerome was painting and people to wash
back.
Then they washed like very rarely.
Well,
you wash your armpits and your junk.
You do like an Irish.
Our real quick,
God damn.
How much did people stick back on?
But I think that's how we're supposed to
be.
We were always trying to kill our
pheromones off of each other.
Do you think that if people just walked
around all day Funky,
that you get used to France?
I don't know.
I think you might like getting used to
the cat litter box.
I smell it every day.
I still listen,
Bro.
When you do Jujitsu,
you get used to stinky smell and I don't
mind you don't mind it.
I do it.
I locked up with this guy the other day
and as soon as we started grappling,
his shirt smelled like pneumonia.
When people leave their age and their in
their in their bag and then they put it
on again a second time,
it's got that smell.
This guy has rash guard for sure.
He wore it twice.
That's what happened.
Some some dudes do that did a bachelor's
in Shit.
They don't have any laundry.
They don't have the time to do it.
They work.
You get used to it.
Yeah.
I actually,
I did wanna like,
listen bro,
I'll say that,
but you would,
but I smell cat litter for the last 10
years.
That is.
Smells
like assholes.
Smell like to human.
Listen,
I actually dangerous.
It's like you have.
You have a bacteria that can give you
disease.
That's why it's so repulsive to you.
Explain that to this guy right now.
He runs a big difference.
Sorry,
I'm just saying shit is bad for you.
Just so you know.
Rude.
No,
but I like stinky people.
I don't even know if it's negative.
You could smell the negative.
However,
and every girlfriend I've had,
whether she knew it or not,
I smell her armpit hard.
Really?
Yeah.
Every time I can't help it.
My nose doesn't work that good.
Sometimes when I get warmed up it works
just fine.
Isn't it amazing how repulsive stinky
pussy is not and this is not hating
statement at all.
I understand.
So like no one's perfect.
It's just a health problem solving.
It's a,
you know,
a bacterial infection or whatever it is.
It's just,
it's nothing wrong.
I mean it happens to people,
but the smell itself is such a warning
sign to men.
There's whatever the fuck it is.
Pussy always smells awesome.
When you get down there,
you smell the hormones and the moistness
of it.
It has like this glazed fucking sent to
it.
Like you could just barely pick it up.
It says it.
You smell a woman through her pussy.
I mean it's a clean,
fresh pussy is a fantastic odor,
but when it's nasty,
when she's got some sort of a yeast
infection or something,
it's horrifying.
Like all your synapses are firing,
all of your senses are going to get away
from that.
The last thing you want to do,
I mean I will eat a girl's ass after she
gets back from the gym way quicker than
I would ever even think about going down
to grow as a yeast infection.
Right now.
Has anybody ever gone down to grow as a
yeast infection?
Cottage cheese is delicious,
but you know,
it's really,
you know,
it's bad also is so pussy where they
don't clean out the soap enough and
you're licking your like this tastes
like fucking wash soap powder.
Rather be licking a dial factory event.
I would have liked.
I liked it.
I liked the muffler.
Have you ever.
Have you ever gone down on a girl and
she had a yeast infection?
At what level does it become a yeast
infection?
I mean at one point,
if I get it there,
event beyond it,
then it stinks,
but I,
I'm sure that does period blood this
period.
Blood bug you.
If hands on the wheel blood.
I'm now on the ground.
I've reasonably been turning into
braveheart,
you know,
putting fucking stripes underneath my
eyes.
Fucking drinking that shit.
I think if you're turned on enough,
you don't give a fuck for sure.
That's what it is.
Like whenever I hear like,
well girls will complain.
They will tell you stories about their,
you know their boyfriend won't fuck them
when they're on the rag and he's
disgusted by it.
I'm like,
that guy's not that into you because let
me tell you.
So if a guy wants to fuck you,
it doesn't carry.
If you're pussies read,
right.
That's nonsense.
What is the difference?
If it's,
it's,
it's a slippery and read or slippery and
clear.
I don't know if have an odor.
I don't give a fuck.
That's blood.
If I'm horny and that's it.
That's it.
Oh,
this is going to be some blood part.
It's just blood dude.
It's like eggs and embryos.
Country Breakfast.
My Shit is ready to go and I go into
guerrilla mode.
I don't give a fuck about some bull.
I don't care about it.
I'm going to share your faith and now.
Oh fuck yeah,
I will.
I will eat her pussy time 20 right now.
If Mrs Rogan is period.
I'll,
I'll eat that pussy.
I don't give a fuck.
I like it.
I don't care.
I'm not scared of blood.
Dude.
I got this Werewolf [inaudible]
fixation.
Yeah.
I'm not afraid,
but I don't like was when I first went
to Washington and then you have to take
that,
that cocoon shell on your Dick the next
morning where you can pull it off like a
look and you forget.
Yeah.
You can all be crusted and scaly.
You gotta pick it up.
It's got its little legs still.
Skin sloughs off like wow,
it's a good term man.
Because a primal thing.
These are all like primal messages
that nature gives you.
These are all good things.
It's good for the check.
It's good for you.
You know when you would go down on a
check and you smell her and she smells
awesome and you want to eat her pussy.
That feels good for her too.
That's like extra excitement.
Like you're into it.
She loves it.
And is this just a burst of positive
energy?
That's all good stuff,
man.
Ain't nothing wrong with that.
You know,
and the fact that somehow or another
you,
you're not supposed to talk about this
or it's supposed to be something that's,
you know,
discussed behind closed doors.
That's just because people are afraid.
They're afraid of their feelings,
are afraid of emotions.
They're afraid of looking ridiculous.
Well,
that's our whole culture.
To have like a whole press stop on sex.
Like,
oh my God,
sex,
like,
oh,
what do you draw on?
A lot of us is here because two people
fucked.
That's the.
You can't talk about eating pussy on the
today show.
Why can't I go on the today show?
And just because you don't want to see
those,
uh,
what Katie correct.
You don't want to see that you're trying
to protect you.
They're trying to protect you from gross
women getting horny.
Katie couric 10 years ago and we got
drunk together and talking about.
I was a single man.
Come on Katie.
Correct.
If you want some,
if you want some,
have you ever had some athletes,
some MMA fighter Dick?
You ever have some gladiator car?
Jason Mayhem,
Miller's ready to throw down?
Do you want to be mayhem?
Monkey number four to one you want to
see available.
You wouldn't be in the record books.
Yo our rope with a boner doing the
weather.
Do you want that?
Why would Al Roker get hard?
Do you think Al roker would get hard
from Katie couric,
sister.
That gets more money,
but they hate each other telling each
other in the dressing room.
You are fucking hockey.
How much screen time?
I bet they get shitty with each other.
I don't like to put you through to that
peace.
Fuck you Katie.
You made $50,000,000
this year.
You fucking whore.
Probably yell at each other.
Oh,
you eat the fucking weather.
What do you do?
Your pointed shit.
You think you're talented?
You mean better?
I'm a conversationalist.
You're a fucking side show.
People tune in to see how much weight
you lose.
Know that their managers do that.
Not that.
Do you think they bang too massive?
Katie couric and secrets are being
exposed because of the Internet.
I mean,
look at this.
Mel Gibson.
Oh my God.
No.
Give George W Bush.
Hilarious guy ever.
I love him more than I've ever loved a
male celebrity.
Hilarious.
Because he's a.
he's a train wreck.
He's a train wreck,
but everybody gets to see it.
So he,
he,
I'm sure he must have been a fucking
nightmare to be in a relationship with,
but I don't think we're getting all the
fucking details how to her either.
I think that bitch is fucking cuckoo for
cocoa puffs badly because of the yellow.
The chicks always will agadoo dot.
No,
that's why.
Because she's already done all the work.
Now.
She's collected dividends by recording
them.
Here's the deal ladies,
please.
If anybody talks to you like that,
don't talk to them.
You never hang up.
Don't ever engage in because I
understand she's got a kid with them,
but let's be realistic.
This,
this shit.
Yeah,
but this shit didn't start recently.
Those kind of screams that
motherfucker's been ramping up for
years.
Yeah.
That's years worth of buildup to get to
that point where that kind of crazy is
acceptable.
You know what I mean?
Like you can't release that cracking on
the second day of the relationship.
Right.
To get that kind of crazy,
you got to get to know each other for a
long ass time to the point where you
feel like you could just be completely
insane with our fucking whore.
Hope you get raped by a puck and
niggers.
He starts talking super crazy talk
that's been building up.
I always like a sex thing between them
and they was like roleplaying and she
took the recordings of,
wow,
that's a good conspiracy theory.
Fucking bitch.
You and you can hold your breath going.
You know what he could say if he was
Jacques Queen Phoenix type dude,
he could say this is all performance
art.
That's all he has to say.
He can say it's say to.
He could have a public apology and say
none of this was ever meant to get get
out.
And I definitely took it too far and I
definitely think I got two and a
character and said some shit that was
offensive and I never wanted people to
hear it.
And all I was doing was exploring this
character that I was creating for a new
role about a guy who is very wealthy man
with a Russian bride who was trying to
kill him.
And he was crazy.
So I was exploring this character.
I apologize.
And she took it.
It's way out of contacts and call me.
We can work this shit out,
son.
Bobby.
I want to fuck mayhem and I got it.
Dude.
We're gonna.
Meet you in Malibu.
We'll get some Sushi at Nobu.
Holla.
Did I know Kay,
my friend Kay works there at Nobu.
We'll get you together.
Roe Mail.
We got you dude.
Back twittering.
This exists.
Mel.
This is all just a misunderstanding.
This is a character working on.
I know mayhem knows for sure.
We got you.
Didn't it though,
as a crazy person may him.
Didn't it make you happy that someone
was way crazier?
Yeah.
Like I was like,
whoa.
I would never say some shit like that.
Like I'm like,
I get banana sandwich that I fucking
flipped my lid,
but I would never like.
I don't know,
maybe it's just not in my character
though.
Like I don't lie,
like I wouldn't say anything racist
because I would say some crazy shit,
but I could never make it to that level
where,
where you're like,
shit,
whore cunt.
Then again I don't have any kids so
maybe it made him crazy.
Like when a dog has a baby,
it starts to get super protective.
Dr Drew
says,
and I don't know if Dr.
drew's right,
but Dr drew says that he thinks that
what it is is an imbalance.
He thinks that Mel Gibson is something
wrong with his brain for sure.
Bipolar,
because if.
Yeah,
if he's getting hammered all the time
and the yelling at the cops about.
That was the other thing Dr.
drew said he was talking about recovery
and the fact that mel was in recovery
for alcohol and then he might've like
fucked up and fell off the wagon so he
might legitimately be crazy.
Sounds like it sounds like it,
right?
Like,
because that's not normal guy psycho.
He went hog up after he said his piece.
Brian,
you ever met any?
Nobody that crazy.
Yeah.
It's usually a thyroid conditions and
shit like that,
but maybe he just got so stuck into the
lethal weapon.
Really.
That crazy.
Huh?
You mess up.
You who do you know?
That's that crazy.
Uh,
I met a stripper that we don't have to
say names an x.
okay.
No,
not just a person.
Just a girl I know that I used to work
with.
Oh,
that girl got the one.
The one with the hair.
Yes.
That girl and that girl would get that
crazy.
Huh?
Well,
you could tell it was a irritation
brought on by,
you know,
chemicals,
stuff,
you know.
And you could tell it was just one day
was awesome.
Other day it was like the worst storm.
Don't have any medical issues are so
quick to dismiss that shit.
You know,
the bottom line is man,
the,
the body fucks up and sometimes it
doesn't produce the shit it's supposed
to produce.
Right?
Totally.
Oh No.
I just think anytime somebody has a,
you know,
whatever a mental condition at that he
ever had exacerbates with alcohol,
alcohol,
drugs or whatever it may pop up.
Step adderalls that'll make you guys who
write to adderall,
apparently.
Super focused and.
Right.
I tried that and I had to flip out like
that because the doctor said,
oh,
you have add.
Oh really?
I've add.
I've just hyperactive.
Really Mad.
He gave me that stuff and for awhile I
was writing blogs on May have icon
writing whatever band out of nowhere to
start flipping out.
Like losing my mind.
It's like speed.
It is speed amphetamine salts,
that's what it's called.
They didn't even hide the name and a
different name.
It's ketamine salt.
That's what it's called.
The generic.
You get generic.
It's methamphetamine salts.
Generic for adderall.
Like,
Whoa,
they're selling this to kids.
Brian,
look that up because it made me crazy.
I was like,
chemical term is.
That's insane.
Yeah.
With Google,
adderall,
adderall and uh,
and make tactical name chicks take it
all the time.
It's adderall.
I mean,
I've been in Wikipedia,
probably chose to model chicks who take
that as a friend,
as appetite and they just walk around,
super scrawny and ripped up.
Oh my God,
that's so crazy.
Do you take per day?
Uh,
I probably take 500 milligrams sure
about that.
Just wondering what Brian had a weird
bias that better.
I have a buddy who was a comic who's on
the adderall and uh,
he says it helps them tremendously,
right for.
Yeah.
Well he's a dude who's,
he doesn't take care of himself.
He,
his body,
he's in his forties and he looks like
he's falling apart.
He's just one of those dudes just never
been real health conscious.
And,
and he was having issues with energy and
focus and they got them on this adderall
shit in this motherfucker just works his
ass off.
He could just sit in front of the
computer 10 hours at a stretch and gave
it to the,
to the fighter.
The soldiers in his army help.
What do you find or what am I talking
about?
There's greenies that,
uh,
the Vietnam era,
the greetings,
the guys are taking it and going on ruck
marches for like two or three days.
Well,
I thought the Japanese invented it.
I thought they invented it for.
And then they tested it out on kamikaze
pilots.
That's what I had read.
Or maybe I had seen a documentary,
I don't really remember totally,
but it was something on the,
uh,
the creation of methamphetamines and it
was connected to kamikaze pilots at,
that's how they talk those guys into
going crazy and slamming their plane
into boats is that they were all men out
of their heads,
which totally makes sense being in war.
He imagined being over that.
Oh,
a batch army being in war and being left
out of your fucking mind surrounded by
other dudes.
Meth out of your fucking mind.
And everyone's got guns.
Yeah.
But you know what a Jap dudes are like
real serious.
I lived over there.
They're like very,
like,
focused on everything.
Probably like warrior culture.
Yeah.
I love it over there to me is great.
I love it.
Huge Star over there too.
You're,
you're a much bigger star in Japan than
you are.
And I wish that I could find over there
more,
but right now they kind of fall in love
you over there.
You know why?
Because I make an effort and actually my
real charter by Lee,
my best buddy,
I call it my Viki,
that'd be big brother and he's like my
guy and I lived over there and I like
because of the limited Japanese I could
speak,
I assimilated with the Japanese fighters
and I would just be be and you know,
18 Japanese fighters eating at a sumo
restaurant like that.
It would be a bunch of Japanese dude.
And I kinda got used to their culture
and kind of got into it like I was a
fan.
I have a Japanese dude right now.
They're so serious,
man.
You know,
that's not true.
No,
I don't mean I'm not joking around.
I mean about like their,
their,
their energy,
like our warrior spirit.
They're so fucking driven with it.
You know?
It's such an interesting culture.
The culture that like really appreciates
the effort.
Like dudes will lose and get so many
fans.
You know,
dudes will just fight like,
like a warrior.
Go out.
She show heart in losses.
You become more and more popular.
Look at Sakharova.
It didn't matter how many times he'd
lost.
Nobody ever gave up on him.
It's like boxing,
like de la Hoya gets knocked the fuck
out two times in a row.
Nobody was going to go see him fight.
Everyone's going to say hang it up to La
Jolla,
but Sakharova dude,
it doesn't matter how many times he got
his egg scramble cap.
People showed up to watch them fight
again and they cheered him like you were
respected.
A bit of those like brock lesnar versus
where he's getting his ass kicked the
cut back at when I love Japan just for k
one.
I just loved that they put on k one
because if it wasn't for Japan,
like real high level kickboxing,
especially in big heavyweights and shit,
there'd be nothing man.
We're the fucker anybody putting on
shows in America.
I mean there are more shows and shit
like that,
but there's nothing televised.
You know,
there's nothing like that.
Steve built like the UFC from their
negative side where no one had that
Steve built about kickbox that anybody
care to like a stupid movie with high
level guys don't man.
It's so fucking exciting.
The PKA that PKA karate shit in the
eighties ruined kickboxing in America
because everybody got the concept bad.
Brad,
Helen and sheds flippy kicks and that's
like a super,
like,
d level athletes do it.
Such a big difference between kickboxing
above the waist and kickboxing with leg
kicks you add those leg kicks.
It changes the whole.
You've got to be way stronger.
Like you have to be like a strong tough
dude.
Mentally could take it because my legs
are sore right now for this board.
It's trading and I only took like two
with,
uh,
with Shin pads on.
Did you see the shamrock fight last
weekend?
Pedro Noguera.
Shamrock got smashed.
But come on,
he should have.
But the,
he finished him with a leg kick.
Final leg kick.
He sold.
It is so hard to watch,
man.
You Watch,
you just go,
ah,
because you could feel pedro with those
tree trunk legs.
Just the bone just slams into Ken's leg.
And if you look on camera like that for
years,
for years.
So the fight randy had a rehab his legs
for six fucking months.
Oh,
I know.
He has like a weird vein.
Sticking from that fight showed is
random and from Pedro Huizar,
both guys from his own,
because his old wood chop at you so
hard,
which such good technique and he's so
fucking big.
He would jack guys legs so bad.
They would literally never be the same
again.
I'll tell you that.
You know,
you as a fighter.
One of the rare also things that I've
seen in my life,
like I just remember the first time I
kicked somebody real good in the ribs.
I kicked him hard with my shit.
Boat was one of the most amazing
feelings because I never knew boy ty.
I moved to California and trade boy type
for real and kick the pads real hard.
And then I remember the guy came and he
threw a left.
He threw a jab and I turned it kicked
at.
When my Shin went,
like it went into his ribs.
I could feel everything booth right in
there than almost unreal feeling of my
life because I felt his body change
because what I was doing and I was like,
man.
And he was.
He was after that point of the fight,
he was of done like he was like,
oh,
and then he let me beat him up high
because I kicked him.
I got him a good one in the ribs and he
was done after that.
Because you know your body,
your body is meant to go that way.
It's a way to go.
There's some kicks from from taekwondo
that are really effective.
The guys are using now at Connolly's,
bringing back the.
It would piss me off because they're
like that.
You learn how to kick where you're like,
like it's a hard one,
but it's so fast and it's not the same
as a boy Thai kick where you digging
through with the whole body and there's
more time,
fast hair,
faster.
It guys will piss me off.
Just kick me across the face real quick.
Guys are the guys who have the
combination of both types of styles that
have the ability to throw like
taekwondo,
fast kicks,
sidekicks,
and turning sockets,
but they also have the Moitai leg kicks
and the more tight defense is important
to you.
Know you,
you,
you got gotta know how to fucking deal
with those shins slamming into your arms
because those pka guys,
they never got kicked back.
That very rarely did God get his arm
broken the PKA,
but in like,
hey juan blah,
brandon broke his arm.
I mean frank shamrock on his arm broken.
You have to be aware of the leg kicks
to.
So like you're like worrying about,
oh,
this guy's going to kick me in the leg
where you're writing pride ranch for him
to kick your arm off at soccer.
But it's also the shin.
You know,
those other guys just did not understand
the power of the shin.
Everybody was going instead of.
I understand the power.
Yeah,
but here's what that,
if you take away a boy tie guy's leg
kicks,
right and make it five.
PK,
that style of above the waist lends
itself for like slap fights.
Yeah.
It doesn't turn into like a real kick
boxing match where you got another huge
element when you add knees and you just
lead.
Oh,
huge,
huge element that,
you know,
why I thought about a lot and I,
I visualized that a lot and I always
like in my fights I always feel that
okay,
this is the end of my rage with my
hands.
And I go,
I feel about what my legs.
I go,
okay,
that's the end of my range will buy
kicks and I figured that out the first
minute or two and I go,
okay,
that's where I could play.
Okay.
So then,
you know,
with that kickboxing big you got to
stand so close to each other and that
you can't really get a good dig,
you know,
you can't really get there.
There wasn't exciting back out.
So it was like a lot of times guys
standing like rock 'em sock 'em robots
just up kicking.
I mean there were some exciting fighters
like Don the dragon.
Wilson was really exciting.
It was like a little kid crew.
What's that?
Dennis Alexio.
He fought a leg kick style that was.
That was like kickstarter.
But that transition when they were
trying to put a leg kick fights on TV.
I remember Don Wilson fought Alexco on
TV.
I don't remember man.
I was back in the desert sun.
But Don Don the dragon.
Wilson fucked up.
Dennis.
Alexia with leg kicks.
That's how he won that fight.
Yeah.
So,
but once you take that away,
there's not a big like spot where you
can set up to make a hard kick to the.
Aren't you surprised though that someone
hasn't figured out a way to do some sort
of a k?
One thing in America?
I know k one has had a few fights in
America,
but how the fuck is that?
Not on TV.
So like whenever that shits on like the
k one Grand Prix,
I get fired up all the time.
Yeah,
they put it on there.
But you know,
it's one of those things.
Thank God for Mark Cuban and that hd net
man,
I watch more mma because the hd net,
that's a great network.
And they're surprised that no one's got
to kickboxing league.
I think kickboxing,
chuck got to kickbox Shit,
son.
I get a hug by Chuck Norris,
one of the proudest moments of my life.
And I was so pissed I didn't want to go
back and say,
can I take a picture with you and be all
cheesy,
but chuck doors,
when he met me,
he reached out his hand and gave me this
big giant hug.
And he slapped me on the back.
I'm like,
I'm in.
Um,
and do you understand me?
I just got love from Chuck Norris.
You remember any details from that day?
Like that certain smell or a like a
love.
I remember love was in the air.
No,
dude,
we were at Vegas and we were at,
uh,
wcl one of those world kickboxing leads
or whatever the name of it was.
It was vegas or Atlantic city,
I think it was vegas.
I'm not sure.
Anyway,
um,
uh,
I just went up and I said to one of the
guys that was working there,
I said,
do you think I can meet Chuck Norris?
And the guy goes,
yeah.
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
come on man,
and he just brought me over to Chuck
Norris and I was just going to say,
sir,
I'm a huge fan,
very nice to meet you,
and.
But Chuck Norris fucking opens his arms,
gives me this big giant smile and says,
Joe,
what's going on here?
It gives me this big hug,
and he got a hug from Chuck Norris and
lived to tell the tale.
It is.
I wish it did,
dude.
I was for real man.
As a kid.
I was a huge corporate chuck Norris Fan.
Enter the dragon that fight with Bruce
Lee.
All the fucking missing in action
movies.
I mean,
as dumb as they were.
Was that Lone Wolf mcquade?
That was the shed sign.
Come on man.
What a little David Carradine.
Extra points.
Low multiple to chuck.
Norris was the fucking man.
So for me to have Chuck Norris will
recognize me and give me this big hug
and call me by name.
I was like,
Oh shit.
It's like the best birthday present
ever.
Morpheus a lot.
No,
no.
We don't want to do audio.
That would be fine.
I don't want to talk about that stocker
character.
I don't want to give him fuel.
You know what I'm saying?
See baby shaking that ass shaking your.
Your dog's given up on trying to kill
it.
He wants to kick it.
He was a.
He was ready to fucking engaged.
Yo.
He hates squirrels.
Birds and cats.
Like he will fuck some shit up if,
if,
if he could get a hold of it.
I've seen it brought into this,
into a busier on Fairfax and La Brea.
Fairfax said third.
He ran out into the street after a bird
wouldn't.
Let me ask you this.
What do you think about strikeforce?
You like working for them?
Yeah,
so of course everyone's cool.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I feel like they,
they just have certain problems that
will be fixed as time goes on.
But if it wasn't for this battle with
the Diaz brothers,
this,
this thing in post fight thing with
Gilbert Melendez,
anything.
Do you think you would be challenging
for the title right now?
Because Jake just abandoned it.
Toughest fight with them.
Your fight with him was way tougher than
Henderson's fight.
I guess I guess I shouldn't say that
that's not really fair because Dan came
really close to putting them out.
The first one he came closer to jake is
such a damn good fighter.
He like,
he left us.
He went,
fuck it.
I'm just going to keep going.
But from that point on it was a route j
dilla clothes.
I was like,
it seemed like Dan was having a hard
time making weight.
It didn't seem like the normal Dan think
you worked for him and he looked,
he looked.
I kinda run down like,
dude,
I think him making 85 might disagree
with you and I know this because I try
really.
He like walks around like one 97,
but he doesn't like cutting that weight
man.
Well of course [inaudible] duties,
fucking 40 years old.
He does that,
but that's what I'm saying.
I'm saying that at that age I'll get
over it.
I'm sure you get over it.
You know he's a big gut weights weights
excuse what?
Like what are you doing?
Nothing.
He like eight years.
I know,
but when it gets to be 40,
that's really hard to do.
Yeah,
for sure.
Dan,
if he catches you with that fucking
righthand damn,
you got problem.
We all know that dude's got one missile
man.
He knocked out vanderbilt.
Vandelay was left.
Oh,
he thought got a strong core and we
twists.
Oh yeah.
It's super hard punch.
Yeah,
you got fucking problems.
Know.
I mean he's not like a,
you know,
a Masato technique striker,
but God damn,
he's got Haymakers,
you know?
Yeah.
Maybe I kind of gave strikeforce a black
guy.
You know,
I brought some attention to us,
but I gave strikeforce a black eye a
little bit by buying cars of that whole
drama,
but it didn't cause it.
You didn't want to start.
I want to start a fight.
Of course I want to go in there wanting
to hype up a rematch and everybody's on
CBS.
Let's make some money.
Let's,
let's get everybody fired up and
enthusiastic about this and everybody
wins.
It's not like you were going in there
with an angry mean face on now what it
was was it?
It's like,
I dunno,
the CBS not get it,
you know,
everybody was bad at me and I'm like,
guys,
what happened?
Negative here I,
I got jumped on.
I didn't get hurt.
They,
these guys totally did not understand
why you were getting all the blame for
that.
I know the people who should have got
the blame with the people who let you
in.
No one should have let you in.
That was an oversight.
They know that now it'll never happen
again.
That's what you know,
running a business is all about.
No one's perfect.
But once that said,
you know what it was was there was too
many fucking people in the octagon.
There was you who was an unwanted person
in the octagon and you were into
interfering with someone who is getting
their glory days.
The whole thing was just badly run.
It was chaos.
You get a bunch of fucking dogs
together,
okay.
At darkstar ground and shit happens.
You can't get mad at the dogs.
You know,
you just can't look.
I think those guys shouldn't have done
that,
but fuck man.
You know,
emotions run high after victories.
Things happen.
People get crazy and I,
you know,
and what's the worst that happened?
May have got jumped on TV.
You got fucking kicked in the head while
you were on the ground.
I got fined for it and it's suspended.
I'm like,
how long they suspend you for three
months.
Three months.
But if I would have argued with it,
it would have been like dive
bar.
You can't win because win.
If you win,
it sets a precedent.
I know.
When is the last time anybody ever tried
to get a fight overturned or protested
something ever and it came through.
So any steroid tasks,
anything.
A protest is a stoppage or something and
it worked.
No,
it didn't know nobody.
Benji radic protested.
The Scott fire resident wasn't.
Yeah,
I think it was.
You thought it was stopped too soon.
You know what man,
that people fuck up and it's a terrible
thing that people fuck up,
but once they fuck up,
it's very rare that anyone can look
straight into the future with a positive
mindset have usually works out for me.
So who do they have lined up for you in
October?
I'm not sure.
I bet we're trying to put Nick Diaz
together.
Oh goodness.
A little grudge match.
So,
so guess what?
I started grudge bag and it ended up
that way they're going to use it,
you know what I mean?
Like,
okay,
now we've got a grudge match.
Well that would be a hyped up fight.
So that will be an October.
Do you know where it's going to be at?
Nope.
No,
I don't know anything.
I don't know if it's happened yet,
but you know,
I like to run my mouth off and hopefully
make it happen.
Are you bummed out that you don't fight
for the UFC?
No.
No you're fine with it.
You know,
I got a good deal at whatever.
Cool.
Yeah.
The UFC,
the biggest show in town and,
and I understand that like when you see
like,
you know like Charleston and challenging
Anderson for the title,
do you look at that shit and so it got
damage.
That could be my wish.
Yeah.
I wish I could fight Anderson.
It's like one of those things I like
right now at this stage of my career.
Cool.
If,
if,
if something gets worked out where I
could work with that with the future.
Okay,
cool.
But you know right now I have a contract
and you know,
I'm generally pretty happy and you know,
whatever.
How cool you with Dana,
you and Dana.
Cool.
I don't know.
I don't know that she doesn't say hi to
me.
So I'm like,
oh well damn.
They didn't say it me,
but I don't know because you think he's
crazy,
man.
Crazy.
I'm crazy and I don't blame them because
you are crazy.
I'm crazy.
But,
but not the pretty controlled.
And if you,
if I can get on the same page as
somebody,
we can be crazy.
I'll be the crazy guy and you make some
money.
We'll both make buddy.
How long do you think bully beat downs
going on,
man,
the way too long.
I think I'll be old.
Pan for Ellis.
Yeah,
dude,
it's juggernaut.
God,
I,
I thought it wasn't.
And then I did the third season.
I recorded it all and it'll be released.
And how crazy it would be if you were on
bullied,
beat down and you're the ultimate
fighter.
Same time,
Bro.
I already know two bites tv time as the
guy as it is right now.
You can't take it.
No like it.
Fine.
I don't mind,
but what I'm saying is I don't know.
People get sick or bay.
No one's gonna.
Get sick of you.
May Have.
Don't worry about that fellow.
We're here for you.
All right.
Just take a little bit less.
Be 12.
No Man.
What is it about the veto gives you
energy too much.
Be 12.
Dating this girl.
Nice in fucking freaks me out,
man.
Daddy burn your whole body,
your whole body.
You know what got used to it now
and I like you.
I like,
oh,
like it's burning my whole body,
but I like it.
I dated a girl,
got me all the vitamins and whatnot at
Man.
I'm like,
this was the best thing that happened to
me.
That's very important.
Men Supplements.
It's amazing.
Nobody ever it.
You know what?
I just started taking supplements like
this year I've never took supplements.
I would just be like,
whatever.
Wow,
that's crazy.
It's stupid,
but what it is,
because I didn't think that it was that
important but bad.
I feel as a market difference.
Well,
the,
you know what it is,
it's marketed,
it's marked marketed.
Rather if you,
uh,
you know,
listen to people,
like doctors should tell you all you
need is a multivitamin.
All that stuff is nonsense.
So you know why it's because it's not
FDA approved.
Oh,
it's not approved.
Well,
it doesn't mean just because it's not
approved doesn't mean it doesn't work.
Or there's a lot of anecdotal evidence
from people that are taken in that are
having pretty positive results.
There's like nootropics that I take that
make your brain work better.
There's a whole bunch of.
Now give me some of that.
Yeah,
I've got some.
I'll write you down a list of all the
different sharing what it is,
but there's a bunch of different things
that are designed.
A Jew nootropics designed just to
increase cerebral activity.
You know,
you're talking about that.
And I think that we live in a culture
where it's not about living better
really.
It's about just living above the death
line like nobody wants to.
Nobody wants to.
Nobody wants to be famous.
Nobody wants to reframe.
Fantastic.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know,
I,
I had a conversation.
Don't feel fantastic,
is bad and wrong.
That's why you're not allowed to smoke
pot and anywhere,
but California.
Well,
there's that.
You know,
how about men?
How much does it drive you crazy when
dudes who don't work out,
we'll talk shit on,
on exercise and the importance of
keeping your body healthy.
Conversation view where a lot of people
are ignorant and then they take pride in
their ignorance.
When your body works better,
your brain feels better.
It all works better.
The whole thing flows better.
So to zoom in,
but nobody wants to admit that that's
their issue.
You know,
nobody wants to admit that their,
their lack of exercise and everything.
No,
no,
no.
I don't need.
Nobody needs to work out to.
Comics are fucking famous of right.
Comics are always bitching and whining
and they just want to sleep til three
and don't do anything constantly that,
that should have so important for you,
man.
Oh,
well I just think that people in
general,
it's easier to be lazy and that bit's
about it because that's funny.
Did you get positive reinforcement from
people laughing at that?
Like,
Oh yeah,
I hear you work it out to A.
Yeah,
there's a little bit of that misery
loves company,
you know,
but I had a conversation with the dude
once we was talking about like,
what's the point and exercise and what's
the point working out?
I go,
all right,
if I could give you a pill and this pill
would give you a super powerful body,
like ridiculous,
much more powerful.
The normal person,
you could literally take the normal man
and strangle him at will.
You can take him manhandle him,
treat him like a girl and and choke them
to death.
If I give you a pill that would give
you,
that wouldn't.
What do you take it when you want to
have that power?
I mean,
when you want to have this superpower,
I'll give you a pill and it turns you
into a lesson and I'm like,
well,
you can have that stupid I have to do is
work out.
If you train and you do some
kettlebells,
gay related agenda to working as a
salesman at 24 hour fitness legends,
legends in Hollywood got me,
got me under the Tenth Planet Jujitsu,
a affiliation program.
I'm trying to sign people up.
You enjoy working out though where a lot
of people
don't enjoy it.
You know what I enjoy?
I enjoy Jujitsu.
Jujitsu.
To me,
it's like it's an awesome distraction.
I got so much going on in my life when I
get into Jujitsu and I'm rolling some
dude and we are just trying to kill each
other.
You know,
I'm trying to choke him.
He's trying to choke me.
We are battling.
We're pacing ourselves.
I know what this motherfuckers doing.
He keeps going for the deep half sweep.
I gotta keep that under hook.
I got to stop them.
There's like this battle going on and
when that battle is going on,
man,
I don't think about shit else.
I'm not thinking about I need to clean
my office.
I'm not thinking about.
I need to call that dude about this
thing.
I need to get my shit together and write
this new material.
No,
I'm,
I'm just doing Jujitsu.
I'm in that zone because it's so
difficult to do.
It puts you in the zone,
you know,
and it's like a fun fucking game there.
Weber on it.
You need to clean your office a little
bit,
right?
Yeah.
If you only had the passion with
cleaning windex,
that's a new shell.
And with the fucking agro cleaning guy,
you're telling me that Mr Leeds not on
juice.
Look at that guy.
He lost all his hair and Jack,
he looks like he does.
He does,
but no tattoo.
Swollen Shit.
Christoph is a fucking sculpted
specimen.
Kids,
right?
Like bad damn specimen.
Cool.
Motherfucker to him in his girl hung out
with them in England.
Cool Shit.
And Krista was on the ultimate fighter
for people who don't know.
Super Nice Guy.
That's the thing about mma that people
don't realize is how many nice people
there are that are involved in it.
And in martial arts in general,
like some of the nicest people I know
are dudes that have fought and dudes
that train because you have like a
better control your ego.
You're like,
you know,
you just,
you're used to getting your ass kicked.
He used to,
used to finding out your real boundaries
by,
by breaking yourself down,
you know,
by getting to the point where you know,
you,
you literally can't fucking breathe.
You literally are in class.
And when the everyone says time and you,
you drop to your back,
you know,
you literally,
you're broken.
Whereas other people did.
They hardly ever experienced that.
They don't experience the boundaries of
their,
of their drive,
the boundaries of their discipline.
You know?
So like the people that I've met that
are like fighters,
like some of the coolest fucking people
you ever meet in your life,
you know,
they have to show their ass the world,
man,
it's definitely a,
you gotta drop your got to whoever you
are cubs out.
If you have to really be yourself for
things and you have to deal with the
pain and you're like,
oh my God,
I don't want to be a pitch and dad,
you never loved me and shit like that
goes through your head,
you know,
like it's not,
you,
you have to confront these real fears
and real.
You have to confront everything.
And I,
I say all of you guys out there in
cyberspace is be a cage fighter just for
a day.
And there's,
there's growth in that.
There's growth in that confrontation.
You know,
when you understand your boundaries and
you hit them,
you know,
you,
you get to know yourself better.
You get to know yourself better than the
average dude who doesn't do shit with
his body.
You know,
there's something about doing something
really difficult willpower wise with
your body,
like training,
especially training in Jujitsu and shit.
Well,
like there's,
there's battles man.
Or sometimes you know,
you guys got your back and you're
defending and you know,
you could just tap out and this is going
to be over,
but your,
your other side.
Ha.
You know the other side of your brain is
going,
no,
we're going to cut this out as long as
we possibly can.
And there's that like fence that you're,
you're dancing on where you're like,
I only just tap right here,
fuck this cake.
But it's so uncomfortable and so
difficult to get through,
but your willpower allows you to survive
and then you get through and you're
like,
motherfucker,
I got through that.
I thought I was gone.
I thought I was gone and now I'm on top.
Oh Shit.
And now I'm passing.
You know,
it's like this overcoming adversity.
A lot of people never experienced that.
Especially if like physically where your
mind has to control your body through
some uncomfort,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
I know.
I guess you could get the same effect
for like,
I don't know,
run a marathon or do you know physically
where you have to push your body,
the mind and the willpower have to
control the body.
I think it's much more difficult when
you're doing it in a competition like
mma or anything like boxing or Jujitsu.
Anything where it's a dude is trying to
kill you,
then it's much more difficult.
Definitely.
But shit man,
think about the kind of willpower that's
involved in the Tour de France now.
Unbelievable.
Those guys are just peddling,
pumping the legs,
just doing the same movement.
Discipline,
man.
Tim,
when I look at like Lance Armstrong,
I go,
that must be the most boring,
intense motherfucker alive.
Does some boring ass shit is just
peddling semi.
It's not boring.
I mean obviously the racing and it's
awesome countryside and shit and there's
all this attention and all this energy,
but they're doing the same thing for
days.
That shit takes days.
It's like who's the most boring and
test?
Motherfucker on earth.
Let's find out.
Everybody get together,
get on a bike.
What's the favor?
Like a county or something.
Fucking accounting Olympic.
The guys just adding fucking bills up
for fucking six days straight.
Yeah.
There's something about that like sheer
tests of discipline that are so
uncomfortable for me because as a
fighter I have like,
you know,
serious discipline to get inside the
room at fight with other guys for,
you know,
at least an hour.
Like I'm doing that for at least an hour
a day and pretty much my entire life
I've done that.
The other side,
I can't fill out a form without getting
distracted.
Like I bike fitting there.
How's the application?
Was the funniest thing I've ever done
because I'm sitting there like,
motherfucker,
if you put one more paper by faith,
I'm going to slap your fucking notary
public faith.
I like God.
It's like all day just sitting there.
I hate.
I hated it.
That's funny.
Yeah,
there's a different.
It's different because I'm,
I'm,
I'm very like when I look at a lawyer
or whatever,
I'm like,
wow,
you fucking look at papers that read
shit all day.
Like,
dude,
I am the exact same way.
I'm a retard when it comes to filling
out forms and shit and I get onto page
10.
I feel like someone's hitting me.
Someone's,
someone's drowning me like,
stop,
this is boring,
and I think what it is is like you don't
want to see,
you don't want to put your brain on that
low and rpm where you're reading this
and reading that book,
making sure this is okay and make sure
that's okay.
And tell that to every teacher that I
have worked with,
square pegs in round holes,
man,
that's what it is.
You know the,
the big fucking problem with teachers is
they're trying to turn everybody into a
robot that assumes a job out there in
the world and there's people with unique
personalities that could be artists and
no one recognized that.
Whether it's a martial artist or a
singer or a comedian,
no one looks at that as a viable path
for a job.
You know?
So teachers want you to be able to get a
job they want you to do to do,
you know,
what it takes to get a job at some
company and,
and,
and move on.
But let's be honest,
I both people that you have to do,
you can't cater.
You can't cater most schoolwork to
anyone who's an artist,
but there should be some way to
recognize when someone's unusual.
There should be some way to recognize
and part of is that the kids don't have
any discipline and that's why they're
fucking going squirrely and that's why
they can't read and probably their home
life,
but you're not going to fix that.
Okay.
You could try to square out that fucking
round peg and and shoved me into that
whole.
You're only gonna get so far.
You know what you're.
But then you're trying to say,
okay,
let's take all the wacky kids.
I put them in a special class and take
all these kids who are definitely going
to be construction workers.
Put them in this.
No,
I don't think that.
I think there should be other
opportunities.
Be like some people don't want to be
comedians.
You know?
Some people don't want to be singers,
but there should be some sort of like an
avenue that you find is interesting and
you can go towards it in school.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
but there's no viable option for class
clowns.
No viable options for disruptive kids,
but disruptive kids have something.
There's something there.
First of all,
it's a terrible thing.
It's undisciplined.
It fucks up the school for the rest of
kids.
It may be and it's because one kid is
imbalanced because one can probably
didn't get enough attention at home or
one kid had an abusive family and this
is the way he learned how to get
attention by lashing out and focusing
attention on himself.
That said,
you got a kid who's willing to do some
crazy shit that other kids aren't
willing to do now.
Okay,
so you,
you're not going to fix them.
You can.
You can teach him about,
you know,
the consequences of him doing that and
how he's fucking it up for everybody
else in.
That creates bad energy and this is
where we're going to focus your energy,
but you're not going to take away that
energy,
that crazy energy that some people have.
It just needs to be filled.
That was really bad.
I was the kid in high school.
That was like,
if you just applied yourself,
Jason,
you just.
Well,
I did that completely different
direction.
I did fighting I,
that's what people don't understand that
you apply yourself in that way.
Somehow or another that's not valid.
Like because some aren't.
They're like,
yeah.
For me it was art.
I used to draw a lot and uh,
in martial arts.
So those were the two things and neither
one of them seemed like any sort of a
viable career option,
you know,
there was no money in.
You didn't think about animation being a
cartoonist because that's what I
thought.
Either a cartoonist or doing radio.
So the whole time I'm going to school,
I'm like,
you know,
I don't fucking care about math history.
I'm not just going to sleep because I
don't care about any of this.
I'm never gonna use it.
I kind of knew that the whole.
Have you ever thought about animation?
No.
Watch thing about animation
because I was like a huge Disney fan
cartoon fan.
It was more comic books.
I love comic books.
Comic books too.
That's how I got into it.
Yeah.
I definitely had aspirations to be a
comic book artists.
We talked about this on one of the
earlier podcast,
but I just had a really douchey art
teacher in high school and he had me
convinced I was going to have to draw
like diaper ads and shit and you're
going to be boring and bad teachers.
There's so many people have bad
teachers.
I mean,
he wasn't a bad teacher.
He's just a bad socially.
He was a beaten man with no spine.
He was.
He had a week will and he didn't like
being around me.
I was his martial arts fighter.
This kid who was fighting in taekwondo
tournaments,
I was at like taekwondo championship tee
shirts.
I'm also proud that I won all these
taekwondo tournament soda where
Taekwondo Shit everywhere because it was
the first thing I was ever any good at
high school.
I knew that kid.
He was a karate champion,
bro.
I begged that allows like 50.
I begged the spar,
Keith Bart and I didn't realize that I
was scaring him because he like.
I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
we're gonna fight.
You just kicked me.
Use your karate and I know how to
wrestle.
I'm going to try to fight you and then
we'll see who wins that.
I'm telling this to this kid who
committed like,
fuck that.
I found out the future of MMA when I was
15 years old when I was a sophomore in
high school.
Actually I think it was 14.
My friend Steven Arduino was on the
wrestling team.
It was a good wrestler and I wasn't
wrestling.
I was just doing taekwondo and we were
really good friends.
We were always talking about like,
you know,
like just to punch in the face.
I'd be like,
bitch,
you can't take me down.
And we went out.
We went out in the grass and this
motherfucker took me down over and over
again.
It was so sad because it was so easy for
him to tell out.
I had no wrestling at all.
I had no.
I've never even thought about wrestling.
Someone except like fucking around with
my friends and he just went fucking
standard.
Finally put his hand on my face,
shoot a double bang.
I'll be on my back.
No,
no,
no.
It was just me stopped and we were
friends.
It was just me stopping him from taking
me down.
Mixed martial arts.
Right.
My Fat Chubby friend named Pierre showed
me the UFC,
the early ones with the fucking
headbutts and everything and showed me
like valitude Oh,
Brazil at.
He was like,
shouldn't be the doer,
UFC at the time,
but like I 90,
95 or six.
He showed me those and I pedro,
or a Barco who was verses Paul Bartlett
and I was like,
yes.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I was like,
man,
I was like,
oh,
I could do this.
And he's like,
do you want to spar me?
That'll like,
you mean fight in the backyard?
And he's like,
yeah,
we'll spar,
you know,
we'll,
where production was this kind of
martial artists,
I'm going to kill you.
I thought,
Oh,
you know,
bubble be bubbles as the front yard is
giant fat black kid.
He's like 300 pounds is like the
scariest dude.
I beat the shit out of him because I
knew how to fight.
Like I would,
I would always spar around with my dad
so I knew how to box and stuff and
whatever he we go out in the backyard.
We said I had this breakdancing,
Matt that I had.
We laid that down on top of the grass so
we had some padding because I do.
I was going to fuck him off,
man.
We squared off in our hockey chest
protectors.
He fucking spin kicked me into fuck in
my bread basket.
I've never been kick like that.
I was like,
oh my God.
So I went to the Miller,
the Miller standby and it is to move.
I always did.
My Dad taught me and it worked all the
time.
One,
two,
and if that none of that knock them down
on the ground,
you grab his head,
which I did and threw him down on the
ground.
I did that and started wailing on him.
Like I was like,
I'm winning,
I'm winning.
He starts wiggling around and shit and
the next thing I know he locked me up.
I'm fucking waking up in my backyard
looking at the trees like quietly and
he's looking down at me and I'm like,
oh my God.
He's like,
wow,
that was a triangle choke.
I learned that in Gracie Jiu Jitsu.
That was the first time I ever did that
to somebody.
I'm like,
fuck,
I gotta look this shit.
He's tiny.
He decided to fight.
Yeah.
My Dad was looking out the window
laughing at me like,
are you fucking mad?
I was sleeping.
I was like,
I never.
I never knew that there was some magical
shit.
What's wrong?
The ground?
I just figured it's like wrestling.
I wrestled a little bit in high school
and I figured,
you know,
until I realized you have to wear this
tight ass pants on.
I quit,
and then I was like,
wow.
Then he just,
he beat me.
He was on his back.
I was waiting,
I was winning and I saw that on,
but I saw gracie do it,
but I was like,
yeah,
right.
It's just because he's wearing a stupid
pajamas.
So fun thing to be able to do to people.
You know what you don't realize how
powerful Jujitsu is.
Wrestling is.
Were you getting a night nightclub
altercation?
Like push somebody off balance like,
oh my God,
they met like feels like Bambi on ice.
Their feet are all slipping to stand
other shoes on,
man.
You're on the floor.
Those leather shoes are so ridiculous.
Like wearing leather shoes is just be
just going out like in handcuffs.
I like pro wrestling boots when I go out
to the club.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Pro Wrestling all day at least up to the
beat for real.
Get on pro wrestling shoes.
I call a pro wrestling boots because
dude,
they're like,
but you weren't there.
No.
They have their tennis shoes.
They're tennis shoes,
but he looked like classy a shoes and
then they,
they lace up to like super high chicks
love.
When I was young,
I was so stupid.
Every time I bought a pair of parents,
I would have to make sure that I can
kick somebody in the head.
I was like,
practice taekwondo,
kicks with my fucking pants on.
Just to make sure if the shit goes down,
I'm going to make sure I know,
you know,
Yo,
my old man,
he was an army for years,
20 years,
something like that.
And he was like a religion motherfucker
like went to war and kill people with
whatever.
He,
he's these like kind of a bad.
He's an old fucker fat bastard now.
But,
but uh,
he uh,
and he went to Korea,
you know,
to,
to like,
well I don't know,
whatever training or whatever.
And he had a post op at the Korean
border,
you know,
like they do that over there.
He sees there,
he tells me when he comes back and I'm
like 11,
he's telling me this story when I was in
a bar out there,
this little Chinese guy,
I'm like,
Dad,
you're in Korea.
Little Chinese guy got into it with me.
He kicked me in the fucking face.
I'm like,
what would it be filled out?
He's like,
no,
he kicked me in the face.
He bought me a taekwondo uniform with
it.
You need to practice this.
And I was like,
I don't know,
like 10.
And I went to taekwondo because of that
story.
My Dad got kicked in the face,
my taekwondo diarrheas imagine your dad
looking out the window laughing while
your uncle over the sink over the sink.
And he's laughing at me and I'm like,
Damn,
you need a dad like that to become a
jason mayhem.
Make a guy like,
you know,
I know,
I remember the Brazilians,
uh,
when I was doing tournaments all the
time when I was really young,
18,
19,
the Brazilians got a crazy story of me
because I would always tell these
stories where me and my dad will fight
whatever and we'd get into it and,
or we spar around and we'd start off as
a joke and it would get real.
Like we'd fucking really fight.
And I would tell those stories to the
Brazilians.
And then it got a story like,
man,
I heard Jason Miller,
his dad would hit them with beer bottles
to make him tougher to the most American
Indian sound and Brazilian accent.
Fucking tonto and shit.
Great winter north by bad my.
But you get the point.
The guy was like,
yeah,
everybody thought that my dad beat the
shit out of me.
He did,
but like it was a lot of times it was
like,
I remember we were like getting into it
in the kitchen and I was like,
fucking fight with them.
And then he grabbed me around and be
like,
it was,
we didn't call rear naked choke.
It was a sleeper hold.
He got me in a sleeper hold.
I was like,
choking and I wouldn't quit.
He's like,
boy,
tap out boy,
top out,
you know,
and I was like,
I don't know,
14,
15.
And I was like,
he's choking me and choking me.
fuck that.
I'm not going to tap out.
And I just remember him finally.
He let me go because he's like,
ah,
that's enough.
But it was too late.
I remember reaching for the refrigerator
handle.
I think waking up and condiments,
like I put me out.
I was like,
covered in like the fucking band aids
and shit mustard and like,
and he's laughing because I have my
mom's like,
well,
you know,
like dad choke me out.
He was laughing,
oh,
was this an actual fight?
Fight players playing who were playing,
but listen man,
and redneck culture,
you have to understand that if there's a
line that's drawn like your plan and
then you're not really playing anymore,
and then it's uh,
it comes from one step for somebody
biting somebody or I can get a good
shot.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
and I can understand that and I'm not,
I'm proud.
I'm proud that I came from such a
strange.
Like I
don't care.
Like I'm a professional fighter.
I'm not God damn kindergarten teacher.
One Time my dad threw a jolly rancher at
me and hit me in the eye of God.
You're homosexual.
No fucking crying.
Stung.
Just look him in the eyes and eat it.
Well,
two face do to get a jolly read through
to the Ip.
Fucking stung.
He missed.
He totally overthrew it.
Hit me right in.
He was throwing it to you.
God has stored is even worse.
Even abusive.
This store,
his dad's going to get hurt.
So vicious wrist action.
Like softball in college,
right?
Motherfucker.
You ever seen those chicks that throw a
softball on the rubber band thing that
that big step throw harder on late night
tv.
Like who the hell?
Why are softball players watching espn
and how fast I throw that under hand.
I don't know.
Probably like 60 miles an hour,
but the thing is they could do it all
day.
It's like a way more natural movement
than like a regular picture,
like a picture.
That shit blows your shoulder,
your shoulder out at all.
I don't know if it's that they're
throwing it harder.
I think it's the mechanism.
Are you waiting?
Are you saying that there will be some
kid from little league up who's been
taught under head and think about this
with a big juiced out arm.
He could throw that shit super hard.
Wonder.
I wonder because it doesn't seem like
girls can do that shit all day and it
doesn't blow their arm out,
but I think there's something about
throwing like that.
It's.
I think you can get more velocity,
especially naturally,
but I have like flexible tendency shit,
like a real flexible.
When I throw a fucking baseball by our
building's gonna blow out of it's side
like dad,
the same thing he got out of ranger
school.
He didn't make it through ranger school.
He couldn't throw the fucking grenade.
Right.
Same Shit.
Wow.
The bad shoulder.
He talks about flexible tenants.
You could see that shit online if you
watch his fight.
And was it super raw bytes,
man.
Anyway,
he twisted my arm backwards.
I was like,
oh my God,
he's going to break it off and I just
toughed it out and then I and I and then
I got up and I was like,
oh,
it's good.
And I just went and asked the guy with
that same head that he was twisted.
It's the most ridiculous Kamora defense
ever.
If you ever see the road map so bad.
I was like,
I didn't even know it.
Anyway,
Egan.
who's this bad ass Jujitsu?
Black belt.
Bad motherfucker yoked.
Damn,
this guy's a legend.
You fought them in Hawaii and where they
hated me,
they were like telling me to die.
Die On the whole.
But Dude,
you know,
Hawaii is a,
a crazy ass place for people ever.
Hawaiians,
Hawaiians are all just all about.
They're like hippies and that live in
their own lions beat the fuck out of
each other.
They do in movies,
videos in real.
There's definitely,
definitely parts of people.
But then Hawaiian community as a whole.
I think people are friendly,
but that doesn't mean that they don't
beat the fuck out of people beating
the crap out of everybody.
No,
no,
but what I'm saying,
so why people in Hawaii are notorious
for wanting to fight.
It's like a part of their culture.
If you go online,
there's all these,
a backyard fights or Hawaiian backyard
fights.
Dude,
there's so many of them.
There's thousands on beach fights in
backyard fights.
Will dudes meet afterschool kids meet
after school and they just have mma
fights.
Bare knuckle.
They just duke it out on the grass and
Hawaii.
But would you,
would you say that if you talk to most
people,
like how was your trip to Hawaii
brought up,
you're going to the resort and you know,
it's a story about the first time I
fought and super ball.
Here's a perfect example.
Okay.
The first time I fought superbowl I got
cut above the eye.
It was walk around Waikiki at some kid
with a guy from Super Bra.
And I was like,
Yay.
Yeah,
what's up dude?
And he's like,
oh,
what's up man?
Yeah man,
I'm tough.
And I'm like,
oh cool bro.
He was like 16 years old,
15 years old,
some fat white tourist is walking down.
He's like,
well,
what?
He wants this?
And he walks over and bends down,
like he's tying his shoe and he's like
looking at his peripheral vision,
sees this guy walking.
He stands up and the guy bumps into him.
Oh,
sorry man.
This Hawaiian kids started beating the
shit out of him because he's young.
He's so young that it's not really
hurting them like that really hurt the
guy.
But the guy looks up and he's got a
buddy with them,
doesn't help them at all.
The kid starts in Hawaiian,
you call it false cracking.
The guy,
it's a sucker punch.
He like,
gets up.
It's sucker punch.
The Guy,
he was ah,
he grabs on his backpack and jump
kicking him,
jumped,
jumping.
The guy started running up.
He goes,
my first trip to Hawaii,
Hawaiian people are crazy.
Getting Sarah Marshall.
I think so the movie's forgetting.
Sarah Marshall.
There was the bartender who is super
cool.
That was the part of the movie I was
talking about afterwards,
maybe from the movies.
That's what I was talking about.
No,
but afterwards he got kicked his ass.
That's like real life.
Well,
I mean,
why does that?
I've never heard any of my.
Anyone ever say go.
I went to Hawaii.
Dude.
It was fucking fight.
You're talking about going to Hawaii
where you go to resorts.
Lazy Wilco.
The nicest people ever.
But I go up to and I bet you they'll try
to gut.
Yeah.
When you talk to Bj Penn,
Bj Penn talks about growing up in a
wire.
It's always says there's nothing to do.
Everybody just fights.
I'm just saying if you're in that road,
it's definitely more,
you know,
in your face then you like if most
people going to the store and a suburban
neighborhood in Hawaii's,
you know,
or something like that.
No one's saying that Hawaii people are
douchebags.
No one's saying that there.
Is this a bad thing?
No,
no,
no.
I can explain it.
I like to find it there too.
It's kind of the culture that you want
to throw down and there's a mutual like,
let's fight.
Nobody shoots each other.
Like,
let's fight,
we'll fight and then we'll end it out.
Oh,
he kicked his ass and then you get the
coconut wireless.
Everybody knows about it.
He kicked his ass.
That's,
you know,
that it's just the culture.
You know,
and I think that pen came
out of Bj Penn came out of that,
that sort of,
you know,
that kind of competition is what started
as mma career.
That he was this bad motherfucker that
would step to anybody to fight anybody.
He took pride in that and that's why he
became an MMA champion when you're stuck
on a fucking island,
the big island and they ain't that much
people and everyone's just jammed in
together on this rock.
You know,
tensions run high.
Oh Man,
I lived there too.
It's a strange,
strange,
different place because you're,
you're on this tiny island and it's
small because even though it's a billion
people,
whatever,
whatever circles you run in our tight
bit because everybody knows everybody,
right?
It must be a lot of bullshit between
like dudes and girls and God pick
imagined because everybody knows
everybody.
Like that dude's faulconer.
Like when someone breaks up,
she goes out with someone you know,
went to high school with that other guy.
Like it's so weird.
It's weird.
That causes tension.
It's painful.
And you lived on the big island of
Hawaii who was like the main island.
Isn't it crazy though?
The smaller.
It's not a big island.
It's not that big.
It's like the boat.
I don't know why it's the.
It was the biggest one that developed
quickest.
It's so weird.
Most of the times when I've gone to
Hawaii,
I went to the big island,
I went to Maui,
I went to a why,
but when I went to a.
Oh,
I went to,
um,
what's the other one is a little small
one.
I forget what you look.
I know,
but when I went to Honolulu I was like,
God damn,
this is like a city.
It is,
it's not,
it's America.
It's America on wheels.
It's America,
America.
It's the weirdest city ever.
It's like a fucking blade runner movie.
It's like,
here you are in this city with this
incredibly beautiful weather with this
amazing ocean.
Like you are right there.
It's the city somehow or another,
but it's not that polluted the ocean's
not that politically.
Just wash it off.
Would you say is the best why park?
Yeah,
it's all like,
it's like last year,
you know,
like Lanai was gorgeous to the NIH is
really small.
Yeah.
Well I imagine it's even less developed.
The quiet,
quiet.
There's one road I think it was.
I only have like 3000 people that live
on 30 days or something tiny.
It's a.
and it's all like the staff throwing
down,
they tend to look a little fucking
spaced out.
When I was asking for directions,
just fucking three roads.
This bitch couldn't tell me how to get
to the hotel.
It's just like,
I think what's.
Know what here.
Here's the thing,
is that about that.
When I lived in Hawaii,
Bro,
I can't tell you what street to turn on.
I can tell you to get to the Waikiki,
you got to go down A.
There's a seven,
11 at the end of this.
What Road?
You take a right there,
you keep going down,
it turns into a one way and you take a
right,
zippy,
and then use.
So you don't.
Nobody knows the world babes because
there were a lot of bad leaky Makkah and
condom.
Oh whoa.
Hey.
I like what?
Like fucking nobody even knows the name
of this road.
How crazy is that?
Hawaii is a part of America,
but it's five hours away on a fucking
plane.
Alaska,
Alaska is not as crazy.
At least its landmass.
You can drive to Alaska in the middle of
it.
He's just like,
there's land in the middle of that.
Makes Sense.
Totally ridiculous.
We've got to have our ass covered on all
sides for sure.
But I mean it's,
it's incredible that we can call that
American.
It's five hours away on a fucking plane
and then Guam is like sort of America
where a pizza.
It was Puerto Rico.
Puerto Rico is like sort of Puerto Rico
is like considered America though taxes.
So they don't want to be part of it.
Are you allowed to be from Puerto Rico
and just immigrate to America?
So I think so too.
That's why there's so many Puerto
Ricans,
you know,
especially if you go to New York.
Oh yeah.
Oh for sure.
Don Gavin's is fucking comedian from
Boston old legend.
He used to have this joke about.
He says,
real fast talking [inaudible] posten
guy.
He's like,
yeah,
I went to Puerto Rican.
That didn't.
Didn't like Puerto Rico too many fucking
Puerto Ricans.
I don't even know how they fought.
So expensive.
I.
You've been doing standup comedy lately.
How's that going?
Where's,
where's the great mayhem doing?
Don't know.
I know you did already show at the
Improv.
I did already start to show today.
I've been arrested.
A budget vibes.
He didn't even ask me to do the.
I fought the law.
Ours probably listening right now.
No,
he is now.
He's not asleep.
It might be that guy who doesn't care
about fellow ladies and gentlemen,
bringing us back to our final sponsor.
This flashlight.
If you want to masturbate,
this is your home by looking at them.
If you go to fleshlight dotcom too,
if you go to my website,
there's a link and you get 15 percent
off your flashlight.
The weirdest spots or I reckon it's the
best sponsor.
Come on my show.
It's fucking nuts.
This whole thing is crazy.
That's why I've got crazy people like
you on.
Nobody else would have got this kind of
an interview at a mayhem.
We had a.
We had to put it together.
Exactly.
We're hanging,
bro.
Don't do that.
Did you fuck.
Fuck.
Oh,
that's awesome.
It's Queef and all over the mic.
Like feel how natural it feels.
Terrible.
After all the dirty pussy and asshole
we've been talking about.
See if it's salty.
The tester like tested by number four.
Oh,
seven years.
A guy going,
I just want to make cock feels so yummy.
Yeah,
right.
Imagine if some dude did.
Fuck it.
Because you're just going to head to
lunch.
If he knew it was going to the
insurance.
Yeah.
I mean you can't have a faulty,
fake vagina.
Imagine that job,
but that was your job.
You have to do that all day long.
Oh good.
That's ridiculous.
Good Hope by God.
There's probably a job like that.
I'm appalled that this podcast.
I think we've reached the bottom.
This is the end of the line.
We have a website,
right?
Mayhem.
Maynard Miller on twitter.
Yeah.
I may have Miller all across the board.
May Have Miller everywhere.
You don't use my space anymore.
Do you feel bad?
I like.
You
know what?
I know that there's chicks out there
that want to bump me up my eyes,
but I don't really go on there.
I can't even go on there and I got is
when you see a girl that's still on my
space,
like this is my space.
That might be a girl that's retarded
lower percentage if you're.
If you're not on my end,
unless she's picking up the king of the
scraps,
she might be there.
Might be like,
dude,
I am the most popular person on myspace.
Tila,
Tequila part three.
I've got 4,000
friends,
40,000
active friends.
A lot of girls claimed 40,000
friends by.
Really?
Yeah.
I got no bots on who the fuck is left
on?
Myspace was computers.
Log are so old.
They can't even work.
Facebook,
our friend just quit my space.
He used your work there and now I could
finally get rid of my.
My space.
I don't feel bad because I only held
onto it.
I think because of him.
I've hoped that my space is going to
make a comeback because I.
back in the comedy store days,
myspace packed that fucking place all
the time.
That was responsible for getting to on
facebook.
Don't know.
The best is twitter.
Twitter is the best.
Twitter is fun,
Dude.
I like talking to people.
I like.
People send me some shit and I send it
back.
Your fans are way smarter than mine
because you always get cool shit sent to
you and I'm like,
what?
The cool shit to them too though.
Whenever I find a tweet tweeted,
I always tweet it,
tweet shit like that back to me,
but I find out all about a lot of cool
articles and cool science developments
and shit.
I find out a lot of that stuff on people
on a,
on twitter message out to you.
Usually we all share and I don't.
I like stoked you come up with it.
Oh cool.
Joe Rogan put an article and I click on
read it.
There's always so much cool shit on the
Internet,
man.
Have you seen the Deepak Chopra?
Sam Harris,
uh,
debates with them.
I forget the dude's name.
And Deepak Chopra had this crazy cat
lady with them and they're debating God
and it's some brilliant shit,
man.
Sam Harris is a brilliant,
brilliant motherfucker.
He wrote that really good book letters
to a Christian nation.
He's a skeptic atheist character,
but a really reasonable dude.
Have you seen Dawkins versus A.
I can't remember.
He did a.
He did a few where he was kind of a
cheap buck show,
oprah,
but I didn't like his arguments against
deep pocket.
It was very short.
The clip that he used online or in his
documentary is very short.
It was just mostly mocking depok,
but then when Deepak talked to them,
Deepak was actually pretty reasonable
about what he was saying.
They were talking about states of mind
and mood and the ability to help
diseases and cause diseases like bad
states of mind court,
which I,
I definitely think I agree with negative
people.
Like negative energy is manifested
itself in stress.
Stress manifests itself in misfiring.
So I've had injuries before where the
injury keeps.
I don't even notice because like I just
got caveman brain where I get hurt and I
just ignore that part of my body right
now.
I'll step on something and have a bloody
foot and just keep ignoring it until I
have to go to the hospital,
you know.
So I kept doing that but I didn't
realize the puts stress on your
body.
And then I got super sick and I'm like,
why am I sick?
And got a hurt the business because you
get in this mind state of being totally
like feeling bad and irritated and hurt
and that your body breaks down.
Yeah.
You need positive energy and a good
feeling of enjoyment of your life.
Appreciation for everything.
All that good stuff makes you feel
better,
makes you lighter.
It makes you have to work less hard.
Makes life less taxing.
When I'm going through a lot of bullshit
in my life,
man.
Tired all the time,
you know,
it's a lot of energy gets used up by
that.
Don't you find that?
Like if you're in like a bad personal
situation that you're fucking tired it.
Oh totally.
It's depression easily,
you know.
I mean,
it's depression,
but it's also energy.
Just bad feelings.
Somebody hates you.
Someone's mad at you.
Well,
at the risk of sounding like a hippie.
Yeah.
Energies.
It's totally sound like a hippie.
The problem is hippies fucked up a lot
of cool shit.
Hippies connected a bit.
Hippie.
Okay.
Because I've met awesome hippies.
Yeah.
Okay.
But the thought of a hippy is this silly
week,
like just like the all he does like to
lay around the fields.
And
Boulder,
when I was in boulder I got annoyed with
a lot of hippies.
This idealistic,
stupid point of trespass on your
property and go,
are you denying us access to the woods?
I'm like,
fuck you fucking Douche bag.
This is my yard.
And I bought the big yard,
but it's my fucking yard.
How about use the woods over there where
it's just the woods.
You do this.
I owe but did north trail.
This is an awesome trail.
Yeah,
that's why I fucking paid $16,000
a month.
You should head
Mr Smithers get the fuck man.
It's like you want privacy man.
Look,
you're,
you're living full basket of tearing
apart.
It's hippies in the bucket.
Bill Master was a nice dog.
He's cool.
He'll let you know when people there,
but he's not like scary.
I like dogs.
My pit bulls when I used to have pit
bulls,
dad was like having monsters.
That was like,
I kept monsters,
right?
No,
I was running.
All right.
So I was at the north shore and this
dude house I was going to apparently he
was like a famous drug dealer or
something like that and I and my friends
went and ahead of me,
I forgot my swim shorts and I got it and
I walked there by myself and across this
giant yard,
a fucking giant pimples,
sprinty Gabby.
And I was like fuck.
And I was already in the gate like I
could run out,
run them at this point,
no the fuck I got.
I got like a fuck,
what do I do?
What do I do?
And I was like,
stay calm and oh wait,
fuck it.
Like that barked at him.
He stopped in his tracks and barked at
me.
We're best friends after that.
Like it was weird.
It was sometimes a bark at you.
They just want to get close to you and
make sure you're okay.
And then they're friendly.
That's what it was.
I barked at him,
he barked at me and then I went,
here's your hands
are some of the smartest fucking coolest
dogs as pets.
But it's such a pain in the ass because
they just want to fight other dogs.
So they're always.
It's like hanging out with a crazy dude.
The Alpha,
just to get your bite holding.
Let them smell your finger at works
also.
Oh Brian,
you did it again.
How dare you.
That doesn't make sense.
Yeah,
you can.
It's like smelling.
They asked if a dog,
if you let them smell this,
smell your asshole.
You totally respect ever.
You see a big dog.
You figure blast like this.
Cool.
What if he decides to attack and bite
your hand never happened.
So they go into smell mode.
First of all,
they're not going to bite it.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
So you're being honest.
It was actually advise.
Totally,
totally.
Try it out.
You see a pit bull charging at you.
Grab your ass hole,
put a finger in,
let it smell it.
Make sure it's working.
Your theory is faulting you to try it
out.
Some other dogs do.
When they see other dogs and tried to
attack you,
you might have got lucky.
You're just used to smelling.
I've just don't do it.
Don't math
in the room.
Oh,
he did it.
he linked it.
Fucking show is over.
Ladies and gentlemen.
That's the end is the end of the line.
I can't even believe he made a dog.
Smell his butt from his fingers.
Go Wash your hands on your tummy,
Brian.
Oh,
this is so nasty.
Gentlemen.
Thanks for tuning in,
right back.
Thanks to our buddy Jason Mayhem Miller
for being one of the best fucking guest
we've ever had on the goddamn
outstanding good stories.
He's a real dude.
You can catch them on twitter,
mayhem,
Miller on twitter,
Miller.com.
Of course,
bully.
Beatdown.
How many seasons is now going into the
third season?
Ladies and gentlemen,
Dvr that Shit.
You know,
you're going to watch it and look for
him in strikeforce in October against
some unknown victim.
We'll see what's up.
Jason Mayhem,
him Melo representing Brian Reichel for,
uh,
for everybody.
Thank you very much for tuning in and
we'll see you sexy bitches next week.
Love you.